e e
good morning everyone uh the time being
10:00 a.m. I'd like to welcome everyone
to the special committee on covid
response efficacy and I'd like to ask
representative poof to lead us in the
pledge
I'd like to remind everyone that this is
a bipartisan committee tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function in a
science-based fact finding review
specifically acquiring comprehensive
accurate data and all related
information pertaining ther to areas of
particular Focus will include the
administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued outlining the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire and this morning we have
uh Dr Jordan vaugh uh here um and I
would like to welcome Dr vau uh and
would you tell us a little bit about
yourself where you're from and uh
anything else you would like to say yeah
my my name is Jordan I'm actually a uh
an internist uh that practices in
Birmingham Alabama uh I am trained as a
engineer previously my undergrad is in
engineering and then after that went to
med school at University of Alabama
Birmingham and then actually did my
residency there I am Additionally the
son of a physician who was also a
general practitioner I am uniquely a
private practitioner somebody that
actually uh basically has his own
organization and is responsible for
about 200 employees uh we uh take care
of about
150,000 patient visits a year and that
was some of the unique aspects of what
uh I'm kind of tasked with learning a
little about was how to take care of not
only my employees in this you know the
last four years but also how to make
sure that my patients whether healthy or
with chronic conditions were also taken
care of and so that's a lot of where my
expertise came from was just really
trying to find
Solutions um
does anyone on the committee have any
questions for Dr vau or um well I have
one um and just chatting with you this
morning um you were letting me know that
uh you were being contacted by a
physician in New Hampshire yes um and so
your practice and you personally help
people across the country is that
correct that's correct so um throughout
this I actually kind of acquired a
special looking at Co Associated
coagulopathy and microvascular disease
so what we do know about the spike
protein is that it is uh highly
coagulopathic uh that it causes uh
fibrin to form in abnormal ways that are
harder to break down so imagine that
fibron is kind of like a spaghetti that
just came out of the colander that you
can kind of break apart it's involved in
you making clots uh but the spike
protein is able to make uh fibrin more
of like a burnt spaghetti casserole that
that's stuck to the bottom of a
casserole dish that requires a brillopad
to get rid of and so in many ways
working with some folks in South Africa
as well as uh University of Liverpool in
England we have kind of a Consortium of
understanding the concept of
microvascular coagulation issues in
covid and vaccine injury and so uniquely
obviously the vaccine produces Spike
protein and Spike protein can do this
independent of thren thren is usually
what's required to make clots uh
additionally the damage to the inside of
the vessels which is what we call the
endothelium uh causes uh a lot of damage
too so you can get a lot of
microvascular issues that don't
necessarily show up in a typical
cardiological exam or somebody that's
being treated for coronary disease so in
a lot of ways what I treat is getting a
lot of these young a lot of my patients
are very young athletic people
historically that after either covid or
the vaccine now we're almost to the
point that they're bedbound and a lot of
getting those kids back to normal has
been how do we heal the vasculature back
to the level that the vasculature is
working properly so uh the cardiologist
that reached out this week uh is is from
New Hampshire but i' had been taking
care of a patient that had come down and
and been evaluated and treated and he
was just interested that he had gotten
better and he had another patient that
very similar that he wanted to kind of
have a talk with
about uh great uh representative
wary yes thank you madam chair and uh
thank you Dr B for taking my question
um is this related to the myoc cardio
effects that we're seeing in young male
population right now um we we've seen
where you know anecdotally there are
people who are uh Keeling over on
athletic fields we're also seeing
situations where um they've now
recognized this as a formal side effect
in a large population that's received
the vaccine is this related to those
incidents it is specific Al uh there's
most recent um Journal looking at the uh
vaccine injuries in myocarditis and they
compared it to a cohort of adolescent
males males from the age of 15 to 17 and
interestingly enough the Mardis only
myocarditis only occurred in those that
receive the vaccine so the V it seems
like the
myocardial dysfunction uh definitely is
more related to probably the product
itself than actually Co but Co because
of the spike protein um also uh is just
I've got probably 15% of my patients
that are debilitated that never had the
vaccine
either followup so is is do you suspect
that because there's a transmissibility
between with the spike protein vaccine
or we don't really know but I will say
that the spike protein itself regardless
of its source is is damaging to the
vessels and and causes coagulation
issues and people the other thing that
we've kind of looked at is a lot of
these people already had some
predispositions for clotting but those
predispositions were nothing they knew
about until after the fact and so again
some of the things that we've kind of
realized is there are people that are
more prone to injury but those aren't
things that we would have never probably
never investigated previously and so
then we find that out afterwards it's
nice to know it but it doesn't change
the fact that we've got to get them
better represent
beler thank you madam chair and thank
you Dr V for being here um so I
guess my my question is I'm not even
sure if you can answer this but if if
the spike protein is perhaps cardiotoxic
and certainly toxic to vascular material
um is this something that could or
should have been known prior to using
the spike protein to develop the
vaccines on yeah that was you know let
me go through a little bit of my
testimony in that regard but kind of
just starting from that but what I would
tell you I'm again outpatient clinician
2020 presented kind of a broad set of
challenges given the fact that I've got
to take care of both my employees and
then 150,000 patients that kind of seek
my uh business for care uh but as I kind
of went into the literature and tried to
find the best understanding of of SARS
Cove 2 the spike protein as well what
really emerged was the spike protein was
all of the above it was amuno toxic
cytotoxic coagulopathic and
unfortunately also amalog genic and so
it was interesting to me in one of the
big things that I had an issue with when
the vaccine was brought into the
Forefront uh a little unknown to me as
my patients who I are already knew
started showing up with shortness of
breath or other kind of side effects
following the vaccine then they would
also have abnormal clotting uh issues
like d diers that were elevated and but
at the same time I wouldn't see anything
when I would get Imaging to find out if
they had big p pulmonary embolisms or
anything like that uh but I would treat
them as if they did and they would
improve and that kind of led me down the
pathway trying to understand the
coagulation aspects of that Spike
protein but the truth is we did the
spike protein itself we know has been
coagulopathic and then in addition if we
didn't know by the time that the vaccine
was rolled out uh we would know then I
mean basically when we look at back at
March 2020 the the people that I work
with in South Africa one of them named
jao lober who's a cardiac intensivist
South Africa he actually released a
video back in June of 2020 that
basically said we're barking up the
wrong tree this is not respiratory
disease per se it's a vascular disease
that's where it's causing the damage and
that's really why a lot of times even
putting people on ventilators was the
exact opposite of what we would want to
do if you have a pulmonary vascular
issue limiting the blood flow to the
lungs causing lower oxygen levels the
worst thing you can usually do is
increase the intrathoracic pressure and
close down more vessels so a lot of what
I did in acute covid was basically
getting patients uh diagnosed treated
with early treatment and also getting
them on things like anticoagulation and
antiplatelets getting them on home
oxygen and then for the most part
getting them better I actually had to
kind of develop my own uh what I would
call oxygen Angel one of the patients
that I had treated uh her husband uh we
had pulled him out of the hospital uh
and put him on home oxygen got him on
anticoagulants and then she started to
say you know it's kind of hard to get
oxygen and so I we came up with the idea
of her kind of traveling around to all
these patients that might need it after
they had seen me and she delivered the
home oxygen to them and we were able to
actually treat about 500 patients in the
outpatient setting without actually
having them admitted to the hospital and
all of them got
better represent po
off thank you uh thank you for your
testimony could you clarify what's the
difference between uh home oxygen and
putting on ventilator so yeah so a
ventilator so when we breathe for the
most part it's it's a negative pressure
meaning like your diaphragm basically
contracts it creates a negative pressure
and you bring air into your lungs okay
uh when you're on a ventilator that's
what we call positive pressure
ventilation you're basically forcing
more air increasing the intrathoracic
pressure problem with that is that's not
how we're designed to breathe and if you
do that for long you damage the lungs
regardless if that makes sense and so uh
if you can the what we were able to do
was make sure they had adequate
additional oxygen without limiting the
continued availability of the of the
vasculature that actually was still
useful and so basically again home
oxygen was putting them nasal canel or
high flow where they were still
utilizing their diaphragm to bring air
in and out not having air punched into
their lungs like you would in an
ICU
followup uh you also mentioned uh four
properties uh known properties of Spike
protein immunotoxic
cytotoxic
coagulopathic could you repeat the forse
property and what it means
amenic so that means that the spike
protein itself can confer other proteins
to abnormally turn in to different
shapes we call amidogen I mean the kind
of classic disease we typically think
about is a Pyon disease like uh you know
cjd but basically it's an interesting
thing that we find in medicine that a
certain confirmation of a protein can
cause other proteins to conf form to it
and without another what we would call
enzymatic activity and that's a very
dangerous thing we don't like that
that's actually when you think about
amalo agenic you're thinking about all
the diseases you don't want uh when you
get
older representative
vure thank you madam chair um and just
to follow up a little bit on the the
topic of ventilation I'm no physician
but I do have a little bit of a
background in healthcare um from my time
as a paramedic I was aware that we
typically try not to intubate and
ventilate if we don't have to because it
can be damaging it seemed to me at the
time early covid that the rather
aggressive um use of
ventilation was
abnormal throughout our investigation as
a committee we have seemed to find that
the source of these protocols may have
been through the W Health Organization
coming down from the who to the uh CDC
and IH and and from there do you have
any information about where these
ventilator protocols came from and
whether you found them strange most of
them I felt like came from Health and
Human Services in the NIH and but I will
say that no one's name was attached nor
were there any documents supporting such
things and in fact most of the hospitals
would tell you even the protocol for
treatment might have even come from the
cares act a legislative document that
was passed in what was actually
reimbursed for care based on uh you know
how people were treated and that's an
interesting thing to find in its own
right uh the other thing early on I
think some of again going back to
something we talked you know have talked
about it is fear uh there was fear that
if you could intubate the patient that
you could close the the loop and
actually not have exposure to other
people in the hospital to actually
getting covid now that's kind of a full
hearty thing in itself but I think some
of some of the people that was more you
know initially when you talk to ICU
doctors that was some of their thinking
was hey this person has active covid to
keep them alive let's close the the
respiratory Loop to make sure that it's
not exposing other patients now was that
the correct thing to do again we could
debate that but I think that there was
some fear around it if I'm going to take
care of that patient I don't I want them
on a different breathing Loop than my
Loop
um so I'm just wondering about the
timeline here um when did you discover
because covid we all know that the
shutdown happened in 2020 March of 2020
um was when we started seeing an
increase in cases in the US uh New
Hampshire shutdown uh just before St
Patty's Day
um so when we're talking about the incu
uh ventil ventilators when were you
aware that that was not a proper use um
and how did you find that out I guess is
my my question and why why wasn't that
knowledge
widespread so it was by that summer we
understood so summer of 2020 uh the you
know again the one of the great things
that NIH and National libraries of
medicine have done is make it available
to read what the rest of the world is is
doing okay and so if you were actually
diving into the literature and seeing
what South Africa was doing what Italy
was doing what England was doing you
were able to see that people were trying
different things and they had different
results and when those results were
positive and and counter to what you
were told that was when you started
going hm there must be something here so
it it was about that summer that most
people realized that the ventilators
were at at even at best a salvage uh and
it wasn't the correct way to treat
things and you know again I would say I
I I kind of lawed jao lobster a cardiac
intensivist very independent person in
stellin Bosch uh University of South
Africa uh who basically said look we
need to stop putting people on
ventilators the problem was by that time
the the legislation that the government
had put out had kind of codified
treatment as well as payment for
treatment and that actually probably
changed the incentive structures for
taking care of patients in the hospital
with covid
so let me understand this correctly so
what you're saying is that the the
knowledge out there that ventilators
were not the way to go um because this
was not not really a respiratory issue
well yeah it affects the lungs but it
doesn't affect the airway of the lungs
right the airway of the lungs okay uh in
summer of
but legislation and the way people were
paid for treatment meant that they still
had to follow a protocol that was
actually doing
harm
um so my I guess my question is is we
have doctors in hospitals that have
access to the information on what's
working what's not working the same as
you did but are
choosing um to follow a
protocol because of um non-medical
professionals and
dollars most likely I I don't question
that the doctors were trying to do the
best that they could and based on the
protocol that's what they were trying to
do I don't think sometimes as a
physician um you have the flexibility or
a lot of Physicians don't even have the
Curiosity anymore to think that maybe
what they're what they're doing since
it's not working may not be the right
thing and so that is it is true I mean I
I think what I had found and um even at
my state level uh was at had to meet
with the board with was that I would
pull somebody out of the hospital well
first of all the patient themselves was
not even really visited by The Physician
they were visited on the phone uh they
were chastised they were basically put
in isolation and so to me made no no
sense for even if he was going to pass
away why were we doing it under the
conditions of him being in solitary
confinement so instead my my knowledge
base as well as understanding of the
disease process gave me the freedom as
well as the knowledge base to say no
let's do something different and when we
started doing something different it
worked and that's again what Shaka was
doing in South Africa they started doing
in a lot of other places where they had
realized that ventilators were not the
solution represent
beler thank you madam chair um so what
you've just suggested to us regarding
the codification of care within the
cares act really tracks with some of the
other information we've received and
some of the other bigger Trends we've
seen especially with things like the
longstanding uh delegated authority of
Physicians to prescribe off label that
was suddenly removed for a number of
medications during the pandemic period
so I guess my question would
be do you believe that there was amongst
all the fear of the pandemic an effort
to Central plan health care that
ultimately had you know detrimental
effects you yeah I I definitely think
the deferral to your octogenarian in
Washington who hadn't treated a patient
in 30 years was probably not the best
way to treat a new disease process uh
and I definitely think also that uh most
of the time in medicine and this is
probably more of probably more of a
historical view but most of the time uh
very little is uh is discovered within
the confines of the Ivory Towers they're
very good at improving technical
expertise safety the ability to do
things but when a new disease or
something like that comes along it
usually is somebody outside the system
that figures out that the the way to
treat it because again usually a new
disease or a new process requires a
rethinking of how we have treated
something in the
past
um I'm trying to wrap my head around all
of this because I'm not being in the
medical profession um
so do I know you're an internist so I'm
just going to throw this out there um we
heard testimony in our committee about
masking um
and are you seeing within your patients
any detrimental effects from people
being forced to wear masks or um and the
other question would be is um we also
want understand that the virus was I
forget what it was
05 Micron so that even those cloth mask
it could uh penetrate through uh so they
really weren't stopping the transmission
or the receiving of covid is my
understanding if I'm wrong please
correct me um do you know when we knew
about that uh
science yeah you know it was actually uh
in 2019 there was a a study done in a
hospital setting uh assessing surgical
mask and n95 mask on the flu and
actually this was published in I think
the New England Journal I have to I'll
have to give it to you at the end of
this but what they found is there was no
difference and then that actually was a
follow-up study to something they had
done two years before looking at whether
surgical Mass changed the the Dynamics
of a flu in a hospital and again you
know we're talking about uh probably the
best case scenario for running a study
like that having healthcare workers wear
a mask properly wear it in that context
and again both both studies showed no
effect and so that was really again what
was so contrary to what was just
published six months before the outbreak
that it you know all of a sudden was
well this is this is the way to go and
even in in Tony F's emails when you look
at them now he was he was commenting on
it before he changed his mind that based
on the data that we had the data that we
had years and years and years of of of
information now it's hard to do a mask
study and I would actually argue that
probably most MTH Studies have plenty of
you know plenty of confounders plenty of
fallacies I mean it's it's just very
very hard to do a behavioral study like
that so uh since then there's been
studies on both sides uh but it's again
I think the common knowledge was exactly
what you're saying uh it was ineffective
representative Belcher thank you madam
chair and continuing on that same sort
of line of thought around masking we've
heard from our Public Health officials
that they pursued what they call a Swiss
cheese approach to trying to mitigate
the spread of the virus and I think what
they mean by that is Swiss cheese has
holes in it but if you stack enough
layers of Swiss cheese you can cover all
the holes up so I'm wondering do you
actually do you find that to be an
appropriate analogy to those kind of
Public Health um
policies such that when you stack
masking and social distancing and these
other things together they necessarily
have an additive effect rather than a
something
else um I don't think we know I think
your intuition would say maybe but
oftentimes in medicine as well as
science intuition is is not always the
answer
representative weary thank you madam
chair uh thank you Dr Bon
um I'd like to go back a little bit to
the um incidence of
the what you're seeing in the
coagulation aspects and we've heard
anecdotally that um Funeral Home
directors and autopsy results have found
in
um in in looking at people who have
passed
away um that there's an
unusual clotting and coagulation that's
going on in those individuals is do you
have any uh knowledge or you know how
does it and does this relate if so does
this relate to what you were talking
about in terms of the coagulation
effects that you're seeing so the quick
answer is you know obviously in my world
it's a living tissue um it is
interesting and I've actually talked
with some of these uh some of the
funeral directors and actually in my lab
have I have not actually done my
specimen analysis of them but uh one of
the things we're trying to figure out is
what what is the cont content of them
because the content uh would be very
helpful you know does it have a lot of
the same properties of the clotting that
I'm seeing at the microscopic level so
the micr clotting level um but it it
would it it it is the same kind of thing
that we're seeing in the living in terms
of these you know vascular and
coagulation abnormalities and then the
way the clot is formed in these people
is very different than what we had
normally seen so when you compare it to
something that's not related to covid a
clot or uh you know a thrombus these
thrombus are much harder to break down
they're they're different in
kind followup
uh could you could you expand on the
different in kind what what do you mean
by that that's interesting so I mean a
lot of it has to do with that the
protein level how proteins come together
and so in in truth our bodies designed
to basically clot when it needs to clot
but when it's done clotting or actually
those vessels need to be opened up those
things need to be able to be broken down
fairly easily we call that fibrinolysis
the ability to break down fibron or um
and so what we found is that the spike
protein uh causes confirmation of the
fibron into a way that's resistant to
fibron alyis so the body is not able to
break it down and especially in people
that already have some genetic
predisposition to fibrinolytic issues
meaning they don't break stuff down to
begin with it's kind of a cumulative
effect that even compounds so all of a
sudden these people are having uh you
know dvts pulmonary embolisms uh you
know coronary uh thromboses
Strokes uh all of those kind of things
and all of those the incidence of all of
those is on the rise uh and you know
again you could make some arguments
again that's just a correlation but the
uh uh you know just in our research it
seems like there's a pretty good and
it's starting to even come out in the
literature that postco and again most of
the time now most of the research is
looking at
postco uh which usually for a huge
percent of the population would be
postco
postvaccine that uh the incidents and
issues that are associated with coronary
disease heart failure those kind of
things are are are changing in a
negative
way represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and again
to stay on the same line of thought
regarding um clotting which is very
interesting to me um I don't know the
linkage between what what was talked
about with the cavers versus um this
micr clotting you're talking about um
but I always have been a bit of a
natural skeptic and if I hadn't been one
of those people who was in the immediate
aftermath of vaccination I had a whole
host of health problems a lot of issues
I deteriorated for a period of several
weeks before I was ultimately
hospitalized for almost a week and after
taking my blood the very first thing
they did to me was Shoot Me Up full of
Hein yep because I was having abnormal
clotting um only time in my entire life
I have ever had a blood test demonstrate
abnormal clotting so my question would
be do you know how
common that phenomenon of coagulopathy
was either both uh postvaccination and
postco um within the population so the
interesting thing about the studies is
basically we know that everyone that
gets vaccinated or has covid exposure to
the spike protein is going to make this
abnormal fibron and that is
bad the question is who can get rid of
it and how much do you make and those
really determine the what I would call
the the symptoms and the downstream
effects of whether being vaccinated or
having covid so again going back to this
vasc you know barking up the wrong tree
it's not a respiratory disease it's a
vascular disease it's a vascular
phenomenon that's basically what you're
provoking and so again what we have
found and are still trying to find is
what actually makes a person more
susceptible to this but in my uh my
research as well as my uh you know
taking care of these patients the less
Spike the
better uh representative
wary as just to follow up on on that um
with with that abnormal clotting uh and
we talked a little bit about this before
the meeting formally began but what what
sort of treatments as an internist uh
treating your patients what sort of
treatments are you looking at to
counteract this abnormal clotting that
you're seeing so early on in the um
early on in the pandemic or in basically
the outbreak in the spring of 2020 one
of the things that was interesting if
you looked at uh the data of people that
were hospitalized and people that
actually left the hospital after being
hospitalized is there was from
especially some of the New York
hospitals and I'll get you the paper
about it was twice as likely that you
were to leave the hospital alive and
again these were mainly older people at
the time uh if you were on a blood
thinner well people that are on blood
thinners from a morbidity standpoint
aren't healthier than people that aren't
so why is there a selective advantage to
them being on blood thinners and it was
actually that was probably some of the
first suggestion that there's something
here and so um the uh you know when we
think about uh how we have treated acute
covid and that was under the you know
really the the science of of jao lobster
as a cardiac intensivist working with
Risha ptus who's uh who's taught me how
to utilize uh immunofluorescent
microscopy and look at blood um they
were able to look at patients in the
hospital in the you know cardiac
Intensive Care Unit and find that they
all had these amalo uh fibron findings
and they were able to see after they put
them on anticoagulation and antiplatelet
therapy that those things got better but
so did the patient does that make sense
so that was the first clue that
treatment with that was effective
now um move that forward as patients
started to show up in the offices of jao
lober and me who had survived survived
covid or had some typee of vaccine
injury uh and were complaining of
similar symptoms not to the you know not
to the extent that they needed to be
hospitalized but when we looked at their
blood they had similar findings to what
Jaa was seeing in the CCU uh and so it
made kind of intuitive sense to say hey
if the treatment worked for these people
can it work for the patients that are in
the outpatient setting and so that was
our first kind of move into it and so
jao published a uh you know a case load
of probably about 60 patients that he
tried antiplatelet and anticoagulant
therapy on and between us I've probably
treated 2500 patients now uh with a dual
antiplatelet and anti coagulant therapy
um and had a really you know probably
success in the 70% in terms of returning
to normal status now everyone's
different not every bit of long Co or
even how Co attacks the body is all
vascular the immune system is still
involved a lot so there's lots of
autoimmune things that can go on but the
thing that we have learned is that you
can't disambiguate or disentangle the
inflammatory system from the coagulation
system in fact what we call it is
thrombo inflammation you'll probably the
next 10 years in medicine you'll hear
that word a lot because thrombo
inflammation especially of the
microvasculature is responsible for a
lot of other diseases that we talk about
like dementia like you know different
you know cor coronary microvascular
disease other things like that that we
usually associate with chronic diseases
that get you into the nursing home which
in some ways might be a silver lining of
this whole craziness is that we are
starting to understand the
microvasculature better I usually use
the metaphor that imagine that you're
sitting in your shower at home and
nothing's coming out of your shower head
and you call a plumber
and the plumber shows up and actually
digs up your water man in your front
yard and tells you there's nothing wrong
well you'd probably fire that plumber
well the problem is is medicine is still
out in the yard digging up your water
man when the issues are inside the house
and so in that sense that's where we're
going is understanding how to actually
help the small vessels because the big
vessels are in a sense
salt I have a question for you
um you treat a lot of patients uh
and I'm going to make a blanket
statement um I'm going to say that most
everybody has either had covid or been
vaccinated um and some
both um are you seeing a difference
between those that were vaccinated and
those that just had covid and um are you
seeing more uh people uh going to
that have had the covid shot versus
those that have just had covid are you
seeing differences so there they have on
the coagulation part they are very
similar I would say um not you know but
when we talk about things like heart
failure neurological issues autoimmune
issues again we take care of all those
too it seems that the people that have
been vaccinated are the ones that more
likely have those issues than the person
that just had covid and wasn't
vaccinated that has much more primary
microvascular disease that you know is
more easily treatable does that make
sense so it's but that again is just
again an observation of my patient
cohort even though it's large it's still
you know it's it uh it encompasses a a
certain subset of people so people that
are seeking treatment people that are um
that that recognize that something's
wrong so I will tell you historically
you know again as I was treating covid
as you know pulling people out of the
hospital getting them on home oxygen
keeping them alive the world talks and
so there was a lot people just started
showing up after they had been
hospitalized and hadn't gotten better
and that's when we started instituting a
lot of what what Jaa was already
researching in South Africa to say let's
try this and see if we can get you
better from postco issues uh the other
thing was a lot of these people were
very young and so they had this kind of
oh there is a marked change between how
I was before or after Co or before or
after the shot there are a lot of people
in their 60s and 70s that it's much
easier for them or their Physicians to
rationalize that they are just getting
older or or they are just missing a step
and the reality is there's a lot more of
that than I think there we we admit and
when we actually Institute treatments in
some of these people the outcomes are
very similar to too getting back to
being able to think not having to go to
Assisted Living those kind of things so
there's a there's a huge again we're
talking about about 200 people but uh
it's it's fascinating to see that the
answer isn't always you're just old and
uh out of
shape um so I had a uh somebody that
talked to me that was vaccinated I
believe she went for her second vaccine
and then it uh an autoimmune response
happened in her body so that she
wouldn't take any more of the uh shots
um so what you're saying is that Co the
co shot could actually trigger those
autoimmune and because she had
attributed to the shot itself yeah and
that is a real yeah and again I you know
that it's not unique to any vaccination
uh you know our immune systems as I
think we were talking even before this
started is our immune systems are
incredibly complex I would actually
argue that Immunology is kind of one of
the last bastions of medicine the more I
kind of compare it to a a hall that we
think we'll we'll get past this next
door and we'll actually know everything
and we get to the next door and open it
up and the room's bigger than the room
before uh you know the more complexity
there is uh it just the more we're able
to get deeper the more complex it
becomes and so anytime we poke the bear
imagine that you're immune system is a
bear you know you want it to Roar when
you need it to but when you poke it
inappropriately it often Ro it often
Roars and causes dysfunction in the
immune system uh the other thing is a
lot of these people were vaccinated that
already had dysfunctional immune systems
and the worst thing you can do is poke a
bear that's already
awake um now I know uh some folks that
are still continuing I mean obviously it
seems like the covid shot is now like
the flu shot um it's becoming seasonal
in you know that's how I'm perceiving it
um and people are getting five six
um and they think that they're fine and
there's no side effects um and other
people you know stop after two as I said
because of that and then I've known
people that uh have had massary
coronaries and died uh within 48 Hours
of the shot um so it runs the gamut um
you know we H have a campaign that says
uh that that shot is safe and
effective um so knowing that for some
people it probably is maybe safe and
effective um and for others it's deadly
um that's what I'm I've seen across the
Gambit and and just the the small amount
of people that I see you've seen a lot
more people
um what is your opinion of this shot
this covid shot and why is it safe and
effective
so I think it when we say safe and
effective I think it that's because they
say it is um it is not necessarily that
the science BS that out uh again the
original Placebo controlled trial uh has
not borne out what it actually said it
would do and all of the other data has
been what we call OB you know it's
really post talk it's observational
meaning it's it's happened after the
fact and you can you know when we talk
about standards of you know evaluating
something in a randomized you know
controlled randomized Placebo control
trial that data doesn't seem to have
borne out that 95% efficacy rate that
they quoted uh I I would probably agree
that everybody in here knows that that
is not true um but again you know trials
are not the exact same thing as uh as
what happens in the real world but when
there's that big a discrepancy usually a
product starts being questioned and I
think that's that's that's the thing
that I think the public health uh world
has had to deal with is that most people
now know that what they've been told
especially the word effective is not uh
is not true so even if they believe it
is safe I don't find many people that
find it effective at least effective
Beyond a month or two but even that is
is uh is an issue uh safety is also the
other thing is it's hard to uh look at
the data the data in the uh you know V's
database is
overwhelmingly different than any other
vaccine we've ever actually pushed on
people or brought into the marketplace
uh now there's plenty of ways to
rationalize why that is and that's what
you get from the public health officials
of course they like the data when it
shows there's no complaints they hate
the data when it shows there's a ton you
know they use it they use it for them
when it's in their favor they use it
against you know when it's not uh but
the other thing you're bringing up and
what a lot of our research has shown is
that the people that have um underlying
issues that make that vaccine dangerous
for them uh it it's not something that
we most Physicians or even I know
exactly what to test before you would
even give that vaccine and so that makes
it where you know if it's safe and and
effective uh but there's a certain
subset of people that shouldn't get it
we should know that before we tell
everybody to get it we should actually
have a a warning saying people that you
know have sensitivity to this or have a
coagulation issue they should avoid the
vaccine the other thing is is vaccines
are not all created equal and so there
are different types of vaccines and I
actually that is one of the things
that's bothered me the most is they
wrapped this vac they wrapped this new
injection technology in the word vaccine
and vaccines are different in terms of
the mechanisms in which they elicit the
immune system and a lot of the
historical vaccines that we have are
passive and passive meaning your body
interfaces with a foreign antigen and
your body makes an immune response this
is the first vaccine that we have that's
been
marketed that actually utilizes your
cell to make a foreign pathogen and in
that case it is a completely different
vaccine uh we have never uh co-opted the
cell
to make foreign proteins instead we have
exposed the body to foreign proteins to
make immune responses I will say the one
vaccine that is probably the lowest in
terms of side effects and uh and and
serious Adverse Events is the Nova vac
the novavax is a passive protein subunit
vaccine it is interesting that our
government has done nothing to promote
that as a safer alternative to uh to the
MRNA injections but uh there again
there's many reasons that I could
postulate why but uh I will tell you
that the novax is probably the only
thing that I would ever even consider
actually somebody
getting represent
beler thank you madam chair and uh thank
you again for being here to answer all
these questions um so where the covid
vaccine efficacy not I'm sorry covid
response efficacy
committee um so we're looking at
efficacy or the effectiveness of the
government actions the very first
question we ask ourselves when we're
trying to determine efficacy is what was
the point what e you know efficacious at
what so there's been two justifications
offered for the um recommendation of
these
vaccines the first justification which I
think has been pretty
thoroughly blown out of the water at
this point both by your testimony our
state epidemiologist testimony and
others was that these vaccines will um
prevent the spread of covid uh obviously
that's not correct everybody's got covid
vaccinated or not the other
justification that was offered was that
the vaccine um effectively reduces
morbidity and mortality to covid-19
infection so my question is how do you
feel about that second justification is
it correct across all the demographics
for which we recommend it and if not is
it correct for any
demographic well I would say in the
original trial that was not an endpoint
that they actually it was not a primary
endpoint so to after the fact come up
with a new prior end primary endpoint
the FDA usually requires you to do
another trial um instead of just
assuming that it's true from post Hawker
observational data and that has not been
done so again they can argue that all
they want with data that they may
accumulate among again you know cohorts
of patients within Health Systems but
the actual data doesn't bore that out
because that was never
tested we heard in this committee that
there were two trials being done and I
forget the groups I think um one was the
FDA and I'm not sure if the other one
was the CDC or not um but we also saw
testimony that uh the data wasn't
panning out the way they had hoped on
one of the trials and so they opted to
change over to the other trial so
instead of having two separate data
points and two SE separate trials they
both conducted the same trial to get to
the in
so that it wouldn't show negative yeah
um did you hear anything about that or
see anything regarding those trials or
um there there's some suggestions as
well as legal filings that there was
some fraudulent stuff I don't you know I
can't really comment on that knowing um
that I don't have all the information
but um it is not that
uncommon uh in this world that uh again
pharmaceutical trials are an interesting
Endeavor and they're going to want the
outcome to a lot of times be what they
want it to be and I hate to say that but
when we classically think of who gets
you know again looking at the original
vaccine trial that that fizer did you
know 40,000 patients 20,000 getting in
an intervention 20,000 not uh you know
the the intervention trial had you know
five cardiovascular events resulting in
death versus the placebo had
one uh now they said that those people
had heart attacks for other reasons uh
and it wasn't one of the things that
they were evaluating it wasn't
statistically significant but to me that
is significant when you only have a
certain number of deaths anyway the
other thing is you got to realize as
you're talking about in that
40,000 uh person trial you're talking
about
218 something you'll have to have to
look it up but it it's a little bit over
200 cases of Co and that's how they came
up with that number of
95% uh that seems like a fairly
small uh uh you know subset of people
actually getting covid and the you know
it'd be interest if they did just let's
say if they did the trial right now I
think it would be quite different does
that make
sense representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and switch
topic a little bit same vaccine topic
but a little bit of a different era
um I have heard and I believe other
members of this committee have heard um
and through our study we have found the
suggestion that those who have received
multiple doses of the MRNA vaccine
products um May then go on to produce
something called
ig4 yeah which to my understanding and
not an expert has the effect of an
immunosuppressant
um is that is there any reason that that
could be accurate yeah so there there's
a couple things one is you do so it
would be more of a the concept of immune
tolerance and usually the metaphor
people use is The Beekeeper that when he
gets stung by a be doesn't have a severe
reaction because he's been stung by a be
so many times okay um that's a good
that's a good kind of concept to think
about what ig4 means so it's basically
your
immunological um signal to say hey we've
seen this before don't overreact let it
be when we're talking about a pathogen a
pathogen that I just told you causes
fibron to form in an abnormal way and
causes endothelial damage the last thing
you want your body to do is let that
thing be and let it do whatever it wants
so immune tolerance in this case is very
dangerous uh the other interesting thing
is the paper that came out about 12
month ago the novax again I'm not
advocating for Novac here but the novax
didn't do that so it seems to be
something unique to the actual mechanism
of delivery the MRNA uh but um that
suggestion in a normal time would have
halted the
uh probably halted the roll out and
probably had them pull the thing off the
market until they could figure out what
the heck was going on that's how
concerning something like that should
be follow up thank you that's very
interesting um and to follow up on that
same line of thought if there are some
people producing this igg4 as a result
of these vaccines is what they are
producing going to be necessarily
specific to covid infection or is there
any possibility that it could result in
a reduced immune response to other um
pathogens as well I was I would say the
answer to that is we don't know usually
immunological responses are specific to
uh specific viral proteins um I will say
the interesting thing about covid is it
does seem to affect the immune system in
ways the spike protein in in in ways
that cause immune um immune tolerance
slash immune compromised States more
than we've ever seen of any other virus
and you probably have seen that in a lot
of your friends or people you say hey I
used to never get you know a bad cold
but now it takes me out in a sense you
know you get something that used to be
you know something that would last a day
or two now goes into your chest and last
two weeks but we're seeing a lot more of
that the other thing is the uptick and a
lot of these other things I think
there's a CDC um again quoting the CDC
but the CDC having atypical pneumonia um
or walking pneumonia or pneumonia
infections in children right now is kind
of out of control um it's it's very
different than they've seen in in the
past and I think um again it's just
speculation and it's you know
correlation but it seems that uh these
outbreaks of things are again happening
faster quicker and just the the health
or the immune system of of of people in
general is being compromised by the
vaccine but also just covid in
general represent warry
thank you madam chair um Dr Von
um as we learned more about
covid and who was more susceptible to
the effects of that we we initially
there was a perception
that uh maybe older populations could
catch it um as more data became
available we learned that
really the patients who were dying had
multiple
comorbidities associated with this and
um
so kind of two questions how does that
uh play
into
um the premise of this being more of a
vascular disease versus a respiratory
disease and then the second is in
talking with colleagues of yours and
Physicians how did how soon did The
Physician
population understand the demographics
that were really um most detrimental for
catching covid and mo most susceptible
and vulnerable to the disease yeah so
interesting I mean some of the things
that actually covid or the spike protein
actually elicits in the immune system
are uh not good if you are diabetic if
you're overweight there's certain things
like one of the things that we look at a
lot is called interlan 6 and interlan 6
a lot of it's uh it's a it's a cyto kind
that is very powerful and causes in in a
sense what you would call the cyto kind
storm thing that everybody would talk
about you would have this kind of
aggressive issue well interlukin 6 is
stored in fat cells uh a lot of it and
so those people were more likely to
secrete tons of interlan six uh when we
talk about the microvasculature the
microvasculature in people with diabetes
and other uh vascular diseases is
already compromised so if you have more
damage and more issues in those areas
you're going to you know basically
propagate and further the issue to begin
with so it it and looking at most of the
data I mean there was almost the
comorbidities in people that were
hospitalized uh were you know always
almost always
present represent beler thank you madam
chair and to take advantage of your wide
ranging expertise in treating both Co
and uh vaccine
injured I would like to ask about
children in particular now in our
state we reive testimony from our
leading epidemiologists that there were
severe illnesses in children at some
unspecified rate especially I believe
you uh he mentioned um inflammation
disorder that came along with covid if
you look at
our official statistics I believe we
unfortunately had one child pass away as
a result of covid and if you look at the
v's data for our state if I'm not
mistaken I believe and of course it's an
imperfect data set but it implies that
we may have had several children die
after or as a result of vaccination so
my question would be can you tell us
anything about the rates of severe
illness that were seen in children as a
result of covid and also the
consequences that were seen as a result
of
vaccination so on the uh you know PE
kids that had severe covid front I mean
I I you know probably the only people
that I had to put on home oxygen on uh
were patients that probably one was 16
one was 17 both of them had underlying
hematological disorders to begin with uh
things that they were born with that
made them more susceptible to having
issues uh did fine once we got them on
the right things uh but yes it was not
an issue in my acute Clinic uh kids were
not really even up until Omron I would
argue that kids really didn't get covid
um that much it was very very hard for
them to get it uh I don't have lots of
you know different theories for that
Omron was kind of the game changer all
of a sudden kids did get it um the uh
but in my long covid SL vaccine injury I
see a lot of children and so I go from
not seeing anybody in the acute world to
seeing lots of people that have residual
issues and usually these children uh
again the associations that we see are a
lot of massed Cell Activation mass cells
are an immune cell that lives in our
tissue interfaces with the environment
so it's in our eyes n ferx or ferx gii
track skin it's also perv vascular
around the vessel um so these people
were already hypers sensitive to things
historically they're the typical kid
that you know very picky eater very but
they're also a lot of them are
hypermobile so I mean and we can go in
some deep kind of pathophysiology if you
want to understand how that's happening
but they're also very athletic
historically a lot of them are big uh
CrossCountry Runners big cheerleaders
big dancers or gymnasts uh and they've
been devastated and they've devastated
by the vaccine or just covid I would say
it's probably again luckily in my state
very few children were actually
vaccinated which I actually think of as
a as as as a win for us but um it's it's
amazing to me how many of uh these kids
have been affected by covid and the
vaccine in the long term meaning not you
know
followup thank you and thank you very
much for that and based on that um our
state as of right now and as I've said
we receive testimony that our state has
not developed independently vaccine
guidance but we have deferred to Federal
guidance in a rather official capacity
as it stands right now I believe the
DHHS website for children's vaccines
will direct parents to the CDC website
that does advise parents to get their
children vaccinated with the uh mRNA
covid vaccine um what would your
recommendation be to our uh public
health professionals regarding that
particular um
guidance I would I would say use the
data use better
judgment and from any kid that I see
avoid at all
cost represent po
off um thank you Madame chair I I have a
question about diabetes we received uh
testimony from our state epidemiologist
that allegedly
uh covid is uh Associated uh or like in
some cases causing diabetes uh did you
hear anything about it yeah there there
was a recent study looking at that uh it
seems like after covid uh that people
are more likely to develop diabetes um
interestingly enough I I think a lot of
the world's understanding of diabetes
always focuses around insulin and the
pancreas but the reality is a lot of
what goes on when we talk about um
diabetes is more of what we call insulin
sensitivity and metabolic disorder
metabolic dysfunction and so again going
back to again I'm biased because this is
the arei research but when you damage
the microvasculature and the endothelium
and and cause issues out in the
periphery a lot of these people um do
develop you know basically insulin has
to get out to the tissues to actually
cause uh sugar to be uptake by the cell
and if it can't do that very effectively
you all of a sudden have elevated
glucose level
your your pancreas starts to make more
insulin and you get basically an insulin
sensitivity issue which would we would
classically call type two
diabetes represent
wary so if if you're seeing this I'm
just curious how are you treating this
if this is uh you know if you're seeing
this more common I assume this is on the
rise than something we can expect yes
and so some some of the things that
actually are interesting and when we
look at you know there's a paper not too
long ago one of the things the actual
NIH did in their recover trial was
utilize metformin they were surprised to
find that
metformin actually uh prevented long
covid and it actually is a treatment for
long covid but again going back to I'm
not surprised is because you're actually
intervening on the dysfunction that
develops and so if you help the body a
metformin is a biguanide that is
probably a common drug all of y'all
probably heard before but it basically
sensitizes your body to be able to
utilize insulin more effectively and so
again keeping your sugar levels down
while you have covid not damaging the
vasculature and damaging other things
you should actually probably not have as
you know dire of consequences after you
uh have covid so we use a lot of things
that are metabolically mediated I use a
lot of sglt2 Inhibitors which are things
like jardians and farga um in treating
people with long covid who have what we
call post or vaccine injury as well post
exertional malays post exertional
malaise is the concept of after somebody
elicits energy they don't necessarily
pay for it right then but the next day
they're completely exhausted and uh in
my research group what we attribute that
to is microvascular what we call
localized tissue hypoxia meaning instead
of when you go work out at the gym and
you're pumping ir and your muscle says
hey we might want to break down and get
stronger instead in this instance the
muscle says we don't have any Oxygen
we're angry releases signals that say we
need help and you actually get an
inflammatory response and that's a lot
of what we would describe as post
exertional
malays represent po
off uh on on a different topic uh you
mentioned how different countries uh
responded differently and if we think
like what our government should do in
future if there will be a future
pandemic like uh like one question is
like should we look at uh what other
countries doing but also like it can
lead us to a wrong path because every
country had different way of approaching
statistics uh like uh like uh in the US
often it was uh PCR tests that were
giving false positives and uh people
were
over uh uh the number of covid uh uh was
over inflated but in some countries it
was the the way around like Germany had
different type of statistics and like if
you say like oh China welded people
inside the buildings and now they don't
have any death for a week like uh let's
do what China does but if their numbers
are fake like how can we compare with
other countries and if if there any way
we can do this comparison and better so
first thing I I I think of when I think
of kind of an emergency response like
this is the last thing you want to do is
dictate from above what everybody needs
to do because a lot of times the
solutions are going to be from the
people on the front lines figuring out
what works and what doesn't and actually
allowing them to go with their Curious
nature and their Ingenuity to find
Solutions the problem is is again going
back to that what hospitals do well is
they safely do things we know how to do
if that makes sense and when we're
talking about a new virus a new pandemic
the last thing you want to do is hold
the hand you know tie the hands of a
physician on his ability to try things
and change from things that aren't
working and instead that's was the
response it actually they actually
scared the Physicians uh in in a couple
ways they scared the Physicians from
even taking care of paat
which is like telling a fireman that the
fire's too hot all right which is crazy
you don't need a fireman that's scared
of fire uh they also handstrong the
Physicians and said no this is our
formulary this is the treatment that you
have to do despite the fact that it
wasn't working that is just the almost
the definition of insanity and in fact
most of the places where they were
allowed to try things uh had better
outcomes and those outcomes were
because if you allow Physicians to
utilize their knowledge base to solve
problems locally a lot of times those
local problem solvings create ideas and
theories that lead to larger structures
of treating people I mean the first
person to do a coronary bypass didn't
roll that out to every hospital he had
to he had to try it a couple times and
then he got then the actual technique
and the proc procedures of doing that
developed over time to where you can do
it on any Hospital anywhere in New
Hampshire in this it was this is the way
we're going to treat it from day one
without the knowledge of actually how to
treat it which is just asinine instead
what we need is to empower Physicians
Empower freethinkers empow Empower
curious people to get their hands on the
disease and learn how to treat it the
other thing is waiting for a safe
like the vaccine was supposedly the
savior is the worst way to approach
head-on a pandemic and even Dr Redfield
who's a friend of mine would say we are
spending too much time focusing on a
vaccine we should be focusing on
Therapeutics Therapeutics that actually
are antiviral anti-inflammatory and
prevent death these vaccines don't
prevent infection and so from that
standpoint why are we spending so much
time on that I mean you know since what
is it
2022 monoclinal antibodies were pulled
off the market maybe because they
thought they had one meaning like oh
everybody's had Co it's it's over it's
behind us but no CO's still with us it's
damaging a lot of people uh and the
solution damages a lot of people too
right now which is the vaccine that they
have offered up where are we on
developing good Therapeutics for
treating
diseases represent
beler thank you madam
chair
so obviously Co is now emic it's with us
probably always going to be with us um
we've heard
testimony that it is this the natural
course of a virus and we receive
testimony that this is true of covid
that over the course of time it
naturally will tend to become less
pathogenic less
harmful um is there a cause to believe
that the
initial strain of covid truly had a
catastrophic mortality rate and that it
just simply evolved rapidly into
something far safer um or is it more
likely that the initial reports of a
five 6 7% mortality rate were just
extraordinarily overblown yeah well I
that it's that your lad I mean even jbot
aaria in uh s San Marine County or Santa
clir County and I mean just proved he
just did an antibody study which by the
way should have been the first thing
anybody had done and just showed you the
prevalence of it and what they found was
it was you know again point you know
there's already a significant amount of
people within the county that had had
covid and this was you know spring of
20120 um and so when you actually add in
those statistics the uh the mortality
rate comes back down to it's still
probably at that time more deadly than
the flu but it was not anywhere near the
56% that was quoted because again if
your denominator only includes cases
that have been diagnosed that's a very I
mean I thought we got past that a
hundred years ago in
medicine um I have a couple of questions
and uh one of them was on the novax that
you keep um uh that you said a couple
times um that could treat covid um when
was that available um because that is
not mRNA technology yeah so so it was
available at the same time actually um
uh I guess what I will say is just
knowing Dr Redfield talking to him at
the time that he was in the room where
it happened um he and Dr Burks were
overruled they wanted to go down the
protein subunit um vaccine
and uh you know Tony fouchy and Peter
marks wanted to go down the MRNA route
um but again it it has been available uh
there was some in terms of being able to
get it at a large scale both of these
actual products had never been produced
in large Vats meaning they were all you
know small studies even the mechanisms
and the how they make mRNA for the
vaccine study was through a PCR process
versus uh when they actually rolled it
out to the rest of of of the country
they utilized what we call a batched
eoli process they actually used uh
organisms to make it so even it was a
different in kind even compared to what
was actually in the study uh they
actually in the regulatory documents
call it manufacturing process one
manufacturing process 2 most people got
manufacturing process 2 which was not
the way they processed or made the MRNA
for the study the novavax um was uh was
was again the protein subunit vaccine is
a much older technology um and so it was
much more uh again you're still being
exposed to the spike protein but your
body is not becoming a factory for it
but it's always it it has been available
it was not the wh knighted government uh
preferred uh
shot represent beler thank you madam
chair and on on that topic with the um
the existence of pre-existing tested
technology versus new
technology um and the particular
individuals who were Champaigne which
and I certainly don't intend to sit here
and guess at the keys anyone's heart or
attempt to indict anybody at all but do
you feel that there is a
problem that some of the people involved
with championing the MRNA technology
were members of a branch of government
that that simultaneously held part of
the patent for that technology and may
have stood the profit from it yeah there
there was definitely a self-benefit to
the to having a technology that was
actually more uh held by and actually as
we see the royalties roll into to the
NIH in the last year which I found
fascinating I think it was they had $300
million I think the last year of course
there's only I think there's about 280
scientists at the NIH so
I mean I I've heard that New Hampshire
they don't pay youall well maybe you
need to become a scientist at the NIH
and you might get some royalties that um
you know but that you mean we're talking
over a million dollars if every
scientist got you know I mean we're
talking about something you know $400
million is not chump change um the uh
other thing is yeah I think the mil what
I would call the medical industrial
complex the uh relationship that
industry has uh with our regulatory
Authority
uh you know again it wasn't until the
'90s to speed up uh drug approval that
uh the actual uh budget of a lot of
these studies that the FDA required
could be uh financed by pharmaceutical
companies um and so 70% of the fda's
budget is provided by licensing fees and
other things uh and if you have that
kind of budgetary
uh involvement then uh you're going to
have a lot more Sway and I think that is
one of the big issues that we have in
government uh what I'd say the NIH FDA
right now the other thing that was
interesting and this has actually came
up when I was uh speaking uh before the
house Judiciary Committee was uh it was
interesting to find the person that
testified with me uh Philip Krauss was
the uh was one of the lead scientists
was cabber which is uh the biologics and
eval you know basically they they
approved biologic things so meaning they
approved biologics blood products um and
vaccines and he was in that uh summer of
2021 uh was being pushed to license the
vaccine and his in his
testimony uh he says that the reason
that he was being pushed and told by
Peter Marx was because we need to
license it so we can mandate it well the
problem is is that is not a scientific
way to license something you don't
license something because you need it
mandated you license something because
you say it is safe and effective based
on the standards that you have set forth
for the people that you represent as a
regulatory Authority now he was removed
from his post and Peter Marx took over
his position and he approved the vaccine
of course Peter marks went on to have 40
YouTube videos promoting the
vaccine interestingly enough the FDA is
not involved in the promotion of
products in fact it's not what they
should be doing they are not an arm of
Industry to uh to advertise they are a
regulatory Authority holding industry to
account and safety for the citizens so
the fact to have that FDA person
involved in
approval basic and actually Thomas
Massie during that hearing played Peter
Marx's videos and it's just so
antithetical to the way that we think
about regulatory
authorities represent p is
off um could could we go deeper into uh
incentives and how um
a physician can be uh free of it and
what uh different uh uh place in it uh
you you mentioned uh uh Federal uh regul
Federal legislation that was
um focusing on certain treatments and uh
putting some monetary
incentivization for it
uh when we talk to our state government
they often say that they are not
involved with setting up treatment
protocols for hospitals that there's
certain associations uh medical
associations that advise hospitals how
to treat uh patients but uh we also know
so so there are some incentives from
federal legislation then I don't know if
it's always a middle man but there's
some
insurance companies uh um working for
government insurances or otherwise who
um
maybe uh put uh some incentives for
doctors and hospitals to treat in
certain way so how does it work and uh
how your practice uh is able to be more
flexible in what you do
so first thing is yes I mean you could
it's probably a the argument to say
well how something gets reimbursed won't
dictate how we treat and that's just
being foolish uh the honest truth is
most of these especially in the americ
medical American Medical system you know
these are the profit incentive there is
uh you know a lot of the times just even
treating covid patients at the time that
the rest of the hospital had to be be
shut down these Hospital administrators
as well as the mdal managers were just
trying to find a way you know and so
trust me they read over the cares act
the cares act also involved a lot of
direct funding to these Hospital systems
but in in addition they found that the
incentivizing of taking care of covid
patients was was quite to their
advantage now in the end at the time
that they made the those recommendations
uh you know we're talking April of 2020
so I don't know that the recommendations
at the time that meaning not the
commendations the legislation were
necessarily had we figured out that this
was the wrong thing to do but the worst
thing you can do is codify a treatment
based on payment before you even know
how to treat it but that's so that's the
last thing I would do the other thing is
um empowering you know one of the things
I did again was trying to find a way of
taking care of healthy people with
chronic additions in my clinic but at
the same time I did not believe that
telling a patient that was sick that
wait until they can't breathe and go to
Theos hospital was the best way to treat
somebody and so what I said was we've
got to find an effective way to do this
within my clinics and so I had um I had
drive up testing but in when these
patients would test positive they would
be able to come into a part of the
clinic that they could get treatment
including monoclonal antibodies the same
day that they were diagnosed positive
okay and so my outcomes were incredible
we probably treated over 20,000 people
and you know had two deaths among those
people and that I mean you're talking
again that's more statistically in line
with with what you would expect but it
was the fact that we had to set up a
system to understand how do we assess
who's positive who needs treatment and
then how do we follow up with them so
again going back to the coagulation
issue on a lot of those people I would
have them come back six days later get a
dher get a chest x-ray and actually
learned that if I implemented
anti-coagulation day six they didn't go
to the hospital day 11 and 14 and and so
again that was just learning as you go
where the signals are and where to
intervene but when you tell all of
society uh Physicians that they can't
see somebody until day 14 you're missing
the most important days to determine
what the heck works and so again goes
back to and you can see this probably in
the Physicians you know the media
reports of Physicians dying and the
Physicians dying in China I'm not really
sure what the motive was at the time but
they scared the hell out of Physicians
and they scared the older ones
especially and I think a lot of times um
that had a deleterious effect to the
patient needing treatment when
Physicians were scared to even touch the
patient follow up uh follow up uh what's
the situation currently with monoclonal
antibodies you said something about them
being removed I remember Florida was
champion in this treatment but then
government kind of n nationalized it and
said it will be centrally distributed is
this treatment Now not available at all
or yes so the monoc there are some still
available monoclinal antibodies uh for
specific reasons they're very expensive
um again uh but it they actually kind of
turned off the spet on monoclonal
antibodies uh in April of 2022 I think
which was kind of Sur surprising uh the
interesting thing was even that is an
example of insanity um so our state
Alabama was uh they actually C were
centrally given the monoclonal
antibodies so what I had to do as a as a
owner as well as an advocate for my
patients is get to know the legislators
really well to find out who the heck is
the state pharmacist and then find out
where the heck these monoclonal
antibodies are okay now most doctors
aren't going to do that I'm a little
crazy great um but it was interesting to
find out I was actively treating
patients day one of positive test having
great outcomes while a lot of the big
hospitals had hundreds if not thousands
of these Doses and they hadn't used them
because they weren't useful day
14 so what did I have to do is get the
legislator involved to get me to get the
med to get the monoclonal doses from the
hospital because the hospital had no
interest in treating people day one
and I don't blame them they were taking
care of the people day 14 but you know
what they they really complained a lot
about all these sick people well there's
a solution how about give the monoclonal
antibodies to me to get people treated
so they don't overwhelm your hospital
but that's not a solution that they ever
thought of so it was a solution that I
had to come I had I had employees
driving four hours to go to some random
hospital in South Alabama that didn't
even know they had 100 doses is that
just to show you again how the kind of
top down approach spread it all out
equally uh has its
consequences followup so follow up on my
previous question so what allows you to
be that flexible do you not take are you
not taking medic and Medicaid and other
insurances or are you under different
type of
Licensing what allows us this
flexibility
so I Am My Own Boss
effectively the patients are my boss I
own my own pharmacies I own my own
clinics I own my own buildings I know
again this isn't the idea for everybody
but at that point there wasn't anybody
that said no you can't do
that and there is a there is freedom of
curiosity in settings that you're
allowed to help and so it was kind of a
calling to say no one else is doing what
I think should be done so why not do it
um but a lot of doctors in the current
world aren't Their Own Boss I mean
actually my father physician in the 70s
and 80s um they were uh you know for the
most part there were private group
practices most of them paid their own
kind of way paid their own salaries they
worked with hospitals but at the end of
the day when there was a disagreement
between the hospital and the doctor it
was because the patient wasn't taken
care of correctly now when there's a
disagreement between the doctor and the
hospital the doctor gets fired by the
hospital the patient doesn't benefit and
that's the problem is we have taken the
ability of Physicians to be curious and
also uh actively be involved in what
they think is best for their patient
which is really the foundation of
medicine represent
wary thank you madam chair um the Dr Von
uh the discussion about treating
patients finally at day 14 reminded me
of a couple of things I I
saw um some studies where they attempted
to treat patients with icin or hydroxy
chloric wind but the problem was those
patients were too far progressed in the
disease they were you know died a few
days ABS you know afterwards and so
there was
no it was a what I would call and I I
have had about 40 years in
the the pharmaceutical medical device
industry so I'm somewhat familiar with
this you know I I thought was a poorly
designed study yeah because you're
treating patients who are too far gone
um so I'd like to get your comments on
that and and then kind of a a second
aspect is that um I think these studies
were also used to then uh state that
hydroxy chloroquin or ior were were not
useful and you know we've found out
since then government agencies have
actually reversed that position um but I
had people telling me that these these
drugs were actually dangerous where uh
having traveled to India several times
uh you know I was taking hydroxy
chloroquin as an antimalarial yeah and I
it's one of the safest drugs around and
so I I was really confounded by
the publicity that was getting out there
versus good science so if you could I
know that's a lot to unpack but if you
could comment on that so the first thing
is yes they were not uh they were not
poorly designed they were intentionally
designed and they were intentionally you
can design a study to make your product
look like it works but it you can easily
design a study that shows you a product
doesn't work and actually that's what
you'll have you'll find in throughout
unfortunately pharmaceutical trials um
and there's a lot of even pharmaceutical
trials that are you know backdoor
sponsored in some ways by the competitor
to utilize the cheaper option or the
more you know the safer option to prove
its uh inferiority to whatever product
might be you know higher up uh meaning
more more reimbursable more new more
patentable um the interesting thing and
this is again
I guess my background as a chemical
engineer uh allowed me to understand
this is medicines are molecules or
natural occurring substances that act on
Maman cells when things that are matter
to us uh that does not limit them from
acting on other mammals cells as well
the other thing is just because they're
approved for one mechanism of action
does not mean they are no longer to have
other mechanisms of action in fact By
definition most medicines have something
called side effects that half the time
are dependent on the fact that they have
other mechanisms of actions that cause
issues okay again this is just basic but
again we're talking about a world that
is acting completely crazy uh hydroxy
chloroquin approved in the 70s in my
Harrison's textbook of medicine as an
antiviral
now again does it have efficacy in covid
you are correct that the trials for it
were designed inappropriately the other
thing is in the summer of
2021 the data that they used for the big
jamama and Lancet study didn't actually
exist and it actually took some slle on
the internet to prove that there was
something called surgisphere which was
this guy in Chicago that had a had a had
a female
escort as the head of the I mean it was
it was like once you did a little
background to look and say see this data
set and see the origin of this data set
this data set didn't come from anywhere
legit but the Lancet and and New England
Journal were
so committed to their biases that they
wanted that data to be true even though
it accounted for more people than
actually live in Australia you know like
it it was it was and they all had to
issue an apology but the problem is is
when when when you're looking as a
scientist when you're looking and I
again I have to check myself all the
time when I'm looking for something that
corresponds and and basically uh you
know confirms my
biases I like that meaning I I want to
promote it uh but that's where medicine
exposed itself and so again that
retraction of the dangers of hydroxy
chloroquin uh no one ever published the
retraction that data that was pushed
pushed out in the summer of
2021 is still assumed to be legitimate
even though the Lancet in J in New
England Journal probably one of the
bigger probably scandals that they've
had in a long time uh and they had to
retract things but the retractions never
covered uh same thing with things like
ior mechon uh Iver mechon is a one of
the safer medicines we've ever found in
fact I'd probably argue that half the
stuff on a over-the-counter Pharmacy
shelf is way more dangerous than ior
mechon um but it again provided relief
it provided people the opportunity or
the possibility of treatment and I think
that was what the train that was rolling
toward the vaccine didn't want in its
pathway which was an
alternative uh possibility of something
that effectively treats the
condition followup yeah if I'm if I'm
may just comment on that briefly is that
you're you're right if there is an
alternative treatment then you don't get
emergency use authorization and so if if
any of these things were were to have
been found even moderately effective no
uh emergency use authorization would
have been approved would have uh
facilitated the distribution of the
vaccine yep
I have so many questions
um where to start
um so I guess a basic question would be
is we have heard testimony in this
committee that people felt like their
voices were
squelched that differing opinions from
the medical community were not getting
out there to
heard um in regard to
treatment
um so that there could have been
options um and just in listening to what
representative warry said that if there
were options then emergency use you know
couldn't have been
utilized how was your voice was your
voice being squelched at any time during
the pandemic
yeah I mean you know again at least at
the state of Alabama um it was you know
again the Medical Association of the
state of Alabama the state health
officer are all um kind of in their own
uh world and they were following
probably as your state does whatever the
CDC or the federal authorities say or in
all honesty probably whoever gave them
money but that's just you know in
general um the uh but yeah I mean I was
called down uh I had other Physicians
turn in um turn me in uh Physicians i'
had never met um and uh Physicians would
write letters saying he is spreading you
know lies by saying the vaccine doesn't
present infection well by the time I got
down to the to the board pretty much
everything I was turned into in in for
was actually correct uh but at the time
it just shows you how even within the
confines of medicine uh um uh there is
that uh there's there's tattle tailing
and backbiting and those kind of things
um the other thing that I found uh
interesting was you know that all of
these people uh I didn't understand
their point of doing what they were
doing because uh it didn't make
sense uh didn't didn't make sense to
spend time to turn somebody else in that
was having success in helping people
does that make sense like um it it's
just
very you know but the the one thing I
will say is the other thing that gives
me the freedom to do this is because I
have the resources so uh you know
getting a letter from the board and then
having lawyers uh you know defend you
it's not necessarily cheap um I have the
resources to do it I probably have more
law firms on retainer than I know what
to do with unfortunately but but uh for
a guy like me I guess they picked the
wrong person because I was not scared I
was not squelched by fear it was just
like well I'm going to have to spend you
know $50 $100,000 not it's worth it
let's go and I think that mentality
especially if you're a private
practitioner out independently you know
you don't have a $50,000 sitting around
to defend yourself instead you're like
let me just shut up I got to feed my
family I got to pay my mortgage um and
so so there is that it goes back to why
I have that freedom to do it is because
I also know that uh you know I again pay
my own bills but also have the resources
to make sure that I'm defended
appropriately because you know the other
thing that I was turned in for was um at
uh I went to my own child's board
meeting uh school board meeting uh he
was becoming a kindergarten my wife
loved this obviously because it was uh I
think he had just started kindergarten
that Friday in the board meeting was
Monday and of course I get up there and
and tell them what my thoughts uh in
terms of you know the fact that this is
you know regardless of what you let
let's let's you know basically on a lot
of times I try to debate not necessarily
you know whether they're e efficacious
at getting people you know keeping
people from being affected mine was an
argument of what do we not know and it
can't be good to actually Mass children
during their you know most you know
development Al times of both language uh
you know non-verbal cues their ability
to interact with other kids and and
their teacher having the teacher hug
them I mean elementary school I mean
like your teacher is a big part of your
life she's like literally my kids's
teacher can say something and what I
said doesn't even matter I mean like
it's you know um but I was two
infectious disease physicians at the end
got up and said the opposite and one of
them thankfully the other one didn't I
have a little more respect for him but
the other infectious disease Physicians
said we know that there's no long-term
consequences to Children wearing
masks which just again the guy that's
supposed to be up there with telling us
about the science because he's an
infectious disease doctor is the one
that's really you know spouting the
stuff that's completely opinion-based
and nonscientific and so um but I did
you know call the Attorney General of
our State and ask if I had given up my
right to free speech again I was not I
was there as a parent and a physician
obviously um a parent could make this
argument that's the other thing it
doesn't have to be a you know uh mask
might not be good for my child it's not
a um but uh and asked if I had given up
my right to free speech when I became a
licensed physician in the state and
evidently I hadn't but evidently the
board thought I might have because I was
investigated for it you know
um just based on what you just said and
only because uh we've heard testimony
from
parents um a statement you made was
there was an infectious disease
doctor that said Mass didn't have
long-term effects on
children as an infectious disease doctor
what was his area of expertise with
masking in children to make that
statement none and that's the problem
but even then expertise is not is not
the issue anyway I mean I would say that
no one I you know who knows he could be
correct but I knew that no one had ever
done that study because you couldn't
even get masking children at school
approved through an IRB because it's
unethical like you couldn't have done
that study before covid because no one
would allow it to happen no IRB at any
Institute would say hey yeah let's mask
those kids for six months and see what
happens no that's
unethical so basically there was no
study done to make any blanket
statements of anything yeah
um in regards to studies I think we
touched upon this and I'm not positive
if we touch upon it uh here but prior to
covid there were studies done on
masking uh where it showed that there
was no uh difference uh between masking
and the flu and we knew that the Micron
of the covid virus would be it
wouldn't yeah it was air it was air it
was not a droplet type disease thank you
represent
Bel thank you madam chair and the the
timing is somewhat fortuitous here as I
was just a few moments ago made aware of
a uh official report of findings from
the United States House of
Representatives and Energy and Commerce
Committee uh in a report on a particular
messaging campaign around co9 during the
pandemic period and one of the official
findings of this US House
report is that the Department of Health
and Human Services and public health
officials um made attempts to silence
dissenting scientific opinions during
the pandemic so I'd just like to give
you a chance to comment on that
finding yeah again I mean that's
antithetical to what you know the basis
and Foundation of medicine or just
science is I mean I think dissenting
opinion is the core of well I mean what
I say is alternative opinion doesn't
have to always be dissenting um but uh
it's I mean I it's an interesting world
to live in when the truth is already
decided represent po
off uh I have a question uh about Spike
protein getting into heart like um covid
vaccine uh as I understand it it's
supposed to be injected intramuscular
and I think the idea is that all the
produced Spike protein will stay in this
compounded uh part of of a muscle and
won't go traveling around the body so
can can you come comment on it yeah we
knew that to be true before that it
didn't it wouldn't stay in the muscle
and we know that to be true
after I mean mRNA has been found in
breast milk mRNA has been found in heart
muscle mRNA has been found in ovary I
mean you Nam the
tissue
followup uh Al also a testimonia um I
received here here in the house uh uh
previously and I confirmed it that uh
CDC has a guidance on vaccine injection
and uh on vaccines it's called pink book
it's on yeah CDC website and somewhere
in the middle of pandemic response they
changed the way vaccines are
administered and uh they said in
injected quickly with no aspiration I
think the term is aspiration when you
pull back to check if there's a blood
and that recommendation was based on
some very small study in Canada with a
very limited group that said that
allegedly there's no difference if we
inject quickly or slowly with
aspirational no aspiration so let's
inject quickly with no aspiration but
um the argument for aspiration and slow
injection was exactly not to Rapture the
tissue and not to and limit U the chance
that vaccine will go into blood instead
of muscle yeah yeah I I didn't know they
had changed that but yes the the reason
that you aspirate typically is to make
sure you're not in a
vessel represent beler yes just to
clarify that on the record we do have
that um the change within this
committee's records that was made not
not during covid but in some time
immediately preceding covid was made as
an official recommendation I believe of
a major nursing group based on the
um what they said was that there had
never been proper studies done
demonstrating the efficacy of
aspirations so we should just go ahead
and get rid of it
sounds
about representative po
off oh it's a little bit personal but uh
just La last week uh in my district uh
in Dan Barton New Hampshire one
constituents confided that he was uh
injured by covid vaccine and and still
have lingering issues so uh I don't know
if you can advise like uh um are there
are
any groups in New Hampshire that can
help my constituents especially that
previously we heard that people with
vaccine injuries sometimes they double
victimized with their doctors because
their doctor doesn't want to admit that
the person was injured by vaccine so
sometimes uh uh they B being uh uh
denied uh for the treatment or something
uh or or they're being treated for
something unrelated uh without
recognizing the reasoning for their
illness two two things what I mean one
the organizations like react 19 or uh
lcccc uh again I'm a micro I'm a fellow
of the flccc which is basically consor
of Physicians that in some ways have
become people that question the
Orthodoxy uh but during Co we were
definitely questioning the
Orthodoxy uh but uh the other thing that
I find just in my kind of taking care of
the vaccine injured and the long covid
is um sometimes just allowing them to
know that you heard them but also that
they're harmed by this is isn't I mean
people will cry because they have been
to 20 to 30 doctors that have told them
the opposite and I think that's just
such a it reveals in some ways what
medicine has become unfortunately very
heartless uh and it has lost its art it
has become a uh and by Art I mean
practicing medicine is actually
understanding and caring and in some
sense loving the person in front of you
and seeing that they have value
um public health statistics protocols
those kind of things remove that and I I
sometimes think it's intentional to
create callous
Physicians uh and create you know I
guess in the end will'll be replaced by
AI anyway but meaning like where they're
you know that there's there's no one
understanding what's unique to them but
that is uh that's the hardest part for a
lot of these people the other hard part
and uh there's a we had a webinar about
it um Wednesday is them seeking
compensation for their injuries is
incredibly difficult because they covid
vaccine was not covered under the
vaccine uh harm program the you know
vcap so it is covered under a
countermeasure um program and that
countermeasure program is underfunded I
think at the time that they were last uh
you know questioned under the house
committee there were six members of it
uh so we're talking about you know
thousands of claims and I think eight
total people have been paid out of total
of $400,000 for the whole
country um that that is an injustice in
in my book and um it needs to be
rectified I think there's some things
that they're doing at the federal level
to do that but it is it is even sadder
when you realize that even
the what the the safety net for vaccine
injured that was developed even though
it's inadequate these people don't even
have access
to representative
wary uh thank you madam chair uh just
I'd like to
um we understand you're from Alabama and
that uh is there any particular
legislation or regulations within
Alabama that allowed you to do what you
did um I'm trying to look at it from the
legislator standpoint for a moment and
and say okay how can how can New
Hampshire create this same sort of
environment that allowed you to prosper
and your patients to prosper how can we
create that within New Hampshire and so
do you have any thoughts on that at all
so you
know Alabama is still not a very free
state when it comes to things that occur
within the hospital I mean it's kind of
run by the medical board and the
hospital Association um we have a
certificate of Need for any kind of
hospital bed that needs to be approved
which I think we need to get rid of uh
it limits the ability for private
physicians to find ways to take care of
their patients outside the opice of the
crazy bureaucratic infrastructure that
is the hospital systems gives the
hospital systems tons of power uh but
those are the things that I I think
allowing Physicians and groups of
Physicians uh to form and Thrive uh is
really getting rid of regulatory burden
or uh find yeah I would say the
regulatory burden of creating clinics
opening places for treatment I mean
again I mean I I was lucky I own my own
buildings and had um you know had
clinics that I could have Bunches of
people come in and get infused with
monoclonal antibodies uh and also had
enough space that I could do it in a
place that was you know meaning wasn't
part of where the other people were uh
but I don't but that you know if you
were to say hey I'm going to go open a
clinic to take care of these people just
the regulatory burden to do that would
have been you
know 18 months or something like that so
you need to especially on a pandemic
time of thing and I think they tried to
do this initially they allowed doctors
to cross state borders you know they did
all this kind of stuff because they they
saw in need they needed more people but
there's a lot more of that that you can
do especially in a time of emergency you
know almost taking the rails off for a
in a good way allowing people to prosper
and figure out things and try
things um along the lines um and you
know you don't have to answer um are you
able to accept health insurance at your
clinics yeah yeah yeah I mean I I'm I'm
the same I mean I am basically a you
know a family a classic Primary Care
Organization so meaning it's you know
everything we don't take Medicaid mainly
because we don't see
classically pediatricians see children
so well you know there's a lot of I'll
say we probably don't take Medicaid
because filling out the application
probably takes more time than it's worth
meaning because that's just how many
children we typically see um but
Medicare and every I mean it was you
know basically approved by all but even
that I actually have to hire somebody
that's their full-time job is to
credential my Physicians and make sure
that their you know te's are crossed and
their eyes are dotted for every little
insurance
that exist and that you know again
that's why a lot of these places can't
exist on their own because cash flow and
those kind of things are hard if you
don't know how to do it uh and you don't
have enough volume of scale you know to
hire somebody that literally their whole
job is to make sure that doctors are
signed up for insurance is that's how
crazy the world has
become um and on the lines of Medicare
I'm just curious um
did you have to follow any certain
protocols at your practice in order to
receive reimbursement during the
pandemic I did not because within that
um there was an exception for
office-based
Physicians which thankfully that
exception existed because if it didn't I
would not be accepting
Medicare okay right because we saw that
at our County nursing homes um where
yeah so the regulatory burden is is
becomes more heavy so again going back
to the like why I was I able to do it is
being able to be an office-based
physician that didn't have to interface
with all these regulatory things allows
the freedom to treat patients especially
in a time of a pandemic with Innovative
things and just in the answer to uh
representative War's question uh we do
allow and I know we were trying to pass
but we do allow
concierge doctors now um or you know
practicing nurse practitioners but right
now they have to practice under a
certain license but I think we're trying
to loosen that aspect uh represent
Belcher thank you madam chair
um forgive me I I don't remember if this
was discussed in our hearing now or just
prior to it during casual conversation
but you mentioned that there was a a
fairly dramatic disparity in being able
to receive funding for studies looking
at um covid injury uh and long covid
versus vaccine injury yeah um and I know
personally as somebody who was vaccine
injured I've had multiple doctors um
upon learning that I was a vaccine
injury patient have their demeanor
drastically change and no longer wish to
treat me I've heard the same thing from
other people in a in a similar position
so my question is do you think that
these things are linked and that there's
any sort of official government actions
or messaging or incentives that
contributed to that kind of
environment I don't know that there's an
there's an incentive structure in place
I would think I feel like again um I
think y'all had Aaron Siri testify a
couple weeks ago but uh one of you know
one of the things he challenged me was
how much vaccine education did you get
in med school it's a very interesting
question because there's not vaccine
education in med school there is when do
you give the vaccines education in med
school which is those are the questions
when where how often those aren't
questions of the science or the efficacy
or the safety but instead it's already
assumed that they're safe effective and
people like you don't exist so for a
physician to have to confront that that
is not an easy thing for them to do and
they don't like to do it they don't like
to be
wrong representa pull is
off Could you um do you have any
thoughts on a
framework that is called science-based
medicine
so today we talked about some problems
with public health statistics and that
research uh is sometimes uh biased uh
and there are some conflicts of interest
uh with the research papers and my
understanding is if we then take those
biased research papers and
centrally U mandate uh those findings to
every every doctor despite their own
observation so maybe that's the problem
with current approach because uh in the
science-based medicine sounds great
because science is great medicine is
great but if framework is flood so do
you have any thoughts on how how is is
there are any underlying problems and
are ways to fix
it so I do think you know I went through
medical school in uh 2005 to
2009 and that was at the time that there
was this conversion to what we would
call evidence-based medicine
evidence-based medicine is a fancy term
that you'll probably hear a lot of
Physicians that's not evidence-based y y
y um it is useful for especially
evaluating certain
things uh you know but it
requires a lot lot of information a lot
of robust trials uh that literally the
only people that can afford things to
prove on the randomized control trial uh
versus placebo world are pharmaceutical
industry or some type of government
industry that has a lot of money and so
that means uh that uh if you were to
boil everything down to evidence-based
medicine medicine becomes protocol-based
and doesn't assess and doesn't care
necessarily about the person that you're
taking care of in front of you I think
evidence-based medicine informs you it
gives you help and understanding a
disease process it gives you help in
understanding mechanisms of actions of
medicines it gives you understanding
that hey this does have a therapeutic
effect it doesn't replace the fact that
you're a physician taking care of a
single individual and that single
individual is unique and I think that is
where that disconnect has happened um it
it requires uh I kind of again in my
testimony in front of the Judiciary one
of the things I've always heard you know
you'll heard the word follow the science
and the problem is is that it's not
really a good term science isn't a
leader science isn't an Informer science
is a uh it records data it people
lead people should be informed by
science in how they lead but to follow
science is a really stupid statement
because science itself doesn't make
decisions and it doesn't say that with
this information you have to do this
instead it is just the information it's
the analysis of the data and a leader a
human somebody
with with with skills to interpret it is
the one that makes decisions and so
that's where that's where the whole
missing of that is science isn't a
leader and in fact when you let science
lead it's a crazy crazy
Road representative
beler thank you madam chair and I
think with that statement I think you've
effectively put science in the box that
I would agree where it should properly
go and to continue on that same line of
thinking
because uh science is a tool of analysis
and understanding
um and
we're not everybody has the ability to
become an expert on everything so
they're going to rely on certain persons
and institutions largely to um
authenticate the analysis and the
science so with that in mind what is
your feeling about the present health of
our institutions and particularly those
surrounding the peer review process
so if anything the last four years have
revealed that
you're what I would say medical as well
as you could you could associate Public
Health I like to separate them but your
medical infrastructure the people that
take care of you um it's broken and I
think the last four years exposed that
because when they were um when they were
um approached or affected by some new
thing the response was very inflexible
it was very callous it was very not
Humane um and those an organization
usually kind of exposes itself when it's
put under pressure you know so as much
as you see the signs that say this
hospital system loves and whatever
during covid they didn't really act like
that did they um and the peerreview
process is just as um first of all peer
review peer reviewers aren't paid
uh they usually do it from an academic
Ivory Tower uh the journals themselves
are uh owned by multi uh you know
multinational organizations that
basically have huge revenue and and
profit uh and for me to even get access
to a typical Journal you have to be part
of a university which is what I have to
do on the side to to make sure that I
have you know Library access to all
these journals Because the actual
knowledge is not even you know
sometimes it's not even published but
even when it is published good luck
getting your hands on it if you don't
have an Institutional um an
Institutional sign in um and then the
other thing is is the NIH is really
responsible I think this is again going
back to um how I look at medical schools
now a little has changed where medical
schools used to be state in state or
private institutions that their Charter
was to prepare and teach Physicians to
take care of of the citizens of their
state
um most medical schools have turned into
pre-employment programs for their
multi-billion dollar academic Medical
Center and instead of patient or
Physicians being trained to take care of
the the citizens of the state they are
trained to be a Hos you know a system
physician and that really does take away
their curiosity but the other thing is
the funding for all these institutions
comes from one source for the most part
when you talk about how medical schools
are ranked or academic institutes are
ranked it's based on NIH dollars you
know how much money do they have you
know I think UAB has something like $500
million a year well I mean as a
businessman I've dealt with banks before
and if your uh your business's
Enterprise is based on
somebody's Financial commitment to you
you listen
to that person if they want you to do
something or if they want you not to do
something and I think that's what we
have to realize is the money that is
delved out uh from the federal
government to these academic institutes
is very powerful in um in shaping
thought response and ability to think
freely follow
up yes and along the the same lines of
thinking
um the disparities that exist say now
from 20 years ago as far as your smaller
Physicians Group and your self-employed
Physicians versus your larger
conglomerations seems to have shifted
rather dramatically I think some of us
might make an argument that uh the
Affordable Care Act had the effect of
increasing the regulatory burden on
smaller practices such that many wound
up selling to largers I would say that
the co pandemic was a one twoo punch for
a lot of practices who
likewise um W end up having to sell to
larger conglomerations we I've seen that
personally my own physician had to had
to sell his practice up to a to a
conglomerate um and the reason this is
important to I believe this committee is
that there is a function within the New
Hampshire
Constitution that requires this
government to to take action where
necessary against Monopoly and in and in
favor of um open free trade and
availability so I guess my question for
you is knowing what has happened do you
believe that we're at a point yet where
State authorities or federal authorities
might do well to take a good look at
Monopoly provisions of constitutions and
law
as it applies to the current health care
environment yeah I mean I think at my
own state level um you know one of the
things that I think is you know when we
talk about the power of different
medical boards and those kind of things
I think some of the rules need to be you
know if you're a physician that works
for the hospital there are only so many
seats that can be filled on that board
and there needs to be independent
Physicians so in terms of just your own
Physicians uh whatever your Board of
Medicine or whatever you have you have
to have representation from it it needs
to be less than less than half of that
can be from people that are within
government you know like whether it's
the VA or some academic Medical Center
or some hospital system like who pays
your check because the problem is is
once they flood the boards for these
Hospital associations and medical
associations uh they they follow the
party line and they create exactly what
you're talking about a board that is
that is self U
self-interested um so that's one of the
things that I think is important and
that that has happened over
time other thing that's happened is I
think medical schools need to be uh
teaching Physicians how to run a
practice uh that's the other thing is a
lot of these older Physicians the reason
that they're selling to hospitals is
because the people that are coming out
of medical school they don't know which
way is up when it comes to a balance
sheet um and so medical schools are
responsible for preparing Physicians to
practice in the the state that
they're that they're they're going to
practice and part of practicing is being
able to exist as an entity meaning you
know have a have a clinic and have
availability if we make a bunch of
doctors and none of them can open a
clinic it's not very useful um so that's
another thing that I think is important
I think hospitals are being bought
bought up I think uh Even in our own
State UAB just purchased all the
Catholic Hospitals uh now literally
they're you know went from six different
Hospital Systems to
two there was no discussion about there
being any kind of uh Monopoly power
there and you know less Choice less
competition equals worse outcomes for
patients and I think that's
true um just to go along with that uh we
just had a discussion in this committee
uh believe it was last two weeks ago or
so um
that power politics and money played a
huge role in
Co
um
and the question is is how do we get
around that in the next pandemic so that
um different voices come to the table um
does it just because you have a
different idea or a different opinion
doesn't mean you're
dissenting but as a physician and as uh
an internist and someone who wants to
look at all data um in your profession
would it be beneficial to have different
ideas and opinions around a table um
would you would you come up with a
better solution um whereas it looks like
when it came to the whether we did the
MRNA or the novax uh one factor was
going to
benefit monetarily uh that's not really
a to me that's pretty biased um but
having different opinions yeah two
things on that one even talking about
novaa and mRNA there are other vaccines
there's attenuated vaccines that are
available from India there's a Europe
you know coaxin they they're not
available in the US and you know
interestingly enough uh Tony fouchy was
on TV uh talking to an Indian reporter
from India and uh um he said we don't
need your vac
we've got the
best that's fine if he thinks that but
that's not um you know in a broader
Market especially people that may at the
time if he really cared about
vaccinating larger swats of the
population and he knew there was
resistance to a new
technology as a public health person you
should want all comers if you believe in
what you believe but it showed his bias
really quickly um because you know again
let's say
this is assuming that the vaccines
worked and uh there was 15% of the
population that didn't want to get an
mRNA vaccine because it was a new
technology well why are you rejecting
India's or the European Union's vaccine
that's live attenuated vaccine makes no
sense but that's what we did so again
money power and
politics um what was the other question
I got off on
um during you know we discussed that you
know during another pandemic we didn't
look like different voices were brought
in yeah I I do think that um classically
when you think about medicine medicine
is very siloed it's very specialized
there are very few people that
understand the complexities of all the
things that are going around on them and
in fact they're systematically getting
rid of them because they make them where
you know you're not even you don't get
paid much to be somebody who thinks you
get paid to do um but it requires uh you
know multiple people not just the
experts that are the infectious disease
doctors that have no understanding they
can't even run their own practice about
about anything that has to do with
economics or running business or how
that affect um I think you have to bring
all players involved in every aspect of
your decision and I think uh the uh
Medical Board also needs
to
again encourage Physicians to try and be
involved not discourage them to do
anything other than what we tell you and
so that again that sometimes that's just
the leadership of the organizations
themselves but at the legislature
standpoint having a bunch of infectious
disease doctors or some super specialist
come in and talk about
covid really is very is not useful when
we talk about what to do about it if the
if if it is how do we treat it what
medicines should we use that's fine
that's that's his expertise what you
should do about it from a societal
standpoint in terms of how we run
businesses if you're asking him that
question you're getting the worst answer
available and that's what we
did I agree with you I mean we learned
early on um that how important an
industrial uh hygienist would have been
uh in regards to helping mitigate a lot
of this um I never even knew that when
there was such a person out there um but
um so it's things the little things like
that that we're learning on this
committee that I think can make a big
impact in the future knowing that there
are other players that have different
expertise in different areas um to say
hey look have you looked at this have
you looked at that um and there and if
you look at even in the lay public I
mean beyond what you know my in my world
was Healthcare delivery like how do do I
take care of these patients both on the
chronic side but how do I also get
patients in early figure out what's
going on and get them treated I mean
those are simple things to even but that
wasn't even discussed right uh but
additionally I mean people were solving
things from air filtration to I mean
there were engineers I mean there was a
lot of downtime for a lot of smart
people and we kind of wasted it they all
probably I meaning you know instead of
instead of inviting uh you know
Solutions we basically well these guys
know everything and you know we'll just
wait for Lord fouchy to tell us what to
do I I I think that um and as was
discussed in this committee that we've
created not only we created a lot of
fear but a lot of distrust and we need
to figure out how to build that trust
back up uh with the public yeah I think
there was a a jamama piece again it's
Jamma we're just talking about the
peerreview process but the trust in your
physician has dropped from 71% to 40% in
years that is I mean to have that kind
of drop you know people trusting their
own physician 71% of people did that to
40% and this was jama's own entities
asking those questions so they're going
to try to be probably a little bit Pro
by you know you just think they would be
that that is doesn't doesn't bode well
for the health of so we have a lot of
other problems I mean I think even
currently with uh with a lot of looking
at metabolic disease Ultra processed
foods those kind of things I mean we
need to look at how we're
already being being treated uh and the
other argument I'd have in terms of the
consolidation of Hospital Systems has it
resulted in a healthier
Society or are people getting sicker the
more that we you know the health systems
become bought up the pharmaceutical
industry becomes more involved in the
FDA and the FDA you know I mean to me
the trend lines are all you know I guess
we could blame it on the American
population you know too but it seems
like the people that matter that you
would hope are the people that are
solving problems and making people
healthier don't seem to be doing a good
job I wouldn't disagree um but when
we're talking about statistics there was
something that we talked about earlier
and I just had a question
um when you're dealing with long covid
and vaccine injury is there a
correlation between long covid and those
that were
vaccinated yes could you expound on that
a little bit for me so there are plenty
of people that know the time date and
place that they got vaccinated and were
different um and so they have this
almost time or may they have this moment
in time that they they know um long
covid seems to be more you know
developed after they got covid even a
lot of them didn't really have many
viral symptoms but 2 to 8 weeks later uh
started to notice they didn't think the
same they couldn't run like they thought
they could they have other palpitations
so it is it is interesting to find that
the vaccine seems to be much more Moment
In Time temporal versus the long Co
seems to be developing kind of in this a
little bit more um it's not subtle I
mean it's still pretty Dynamic but it's
not it's not associated it was some
temporal change um I try in my practice
to make sure that I know their long Co
symptoms when they got long covid every
time they got infected and every time
they had a vaccine you know it's almost
like I wanted to come up with kind of a
you know an acronym in uh in gy or OB is
looking at like pregnancies delibery you
know like you have these you know uh we
need to have like a covid 3 injection
for you know like a because it it does
matter it's cumulative so um I guess so
I'm a numbers person so and I don't know
this would be very subjective on your
part but of the population that you're
seeing with long covid uh what is the
say the percentage that NE have long Co
that weren't vaccinated and those that
have long Co that were vaccinated is
there this about about 15% have never
been vaccinated and so 85%
Co yeah thank
you that that's a pretty telling number
um
and and I will say in my state with the
state if you want to just look at
statistics a state that the vaccine
uptake was probably less than 50 less
than
60% that's way out of proportion you
know in in a state that maybe had 85% of
people and you you could say that
there's but in a state like mine where
uh vaccine uptake was low much lower to
have it to have that high of a rate is
is means means
something um I'm gonna oh let me put out
a question um not sure how much longer I
don't know if you have a time limit that
you have to leave uh we can break for
lunch or we can just keep on going it's
your preference we can just keep on
going I guess yeah okay represent po
off thank you Madame chair and thank you
for taking my other question uh uh are
you aware about uh some new data about
sv40 uh that some of those plasmids used
in covid vaccines had um some uh gen
sequence that uh can act as a cancer
promoter and
if uh if that an issue is it an issue
only for one specific manufacturer or is
it common for
allna
vaccines do you know so sv40 is a common
promoter sequence for them to actually
make uh RNA and DNA um there is as you
there's lots of debate on if it's
actually something that has uh cancer or
actually is able to assist even
genetic changes to get up to the
nucleus um it is another example because
actually until it was pointed out by
Kevin mckernin who's a who's an actual
big geneticist historically at MIT that
it existed it wasn't part of the actual
um it was not part of the uh filing like
they were supposed to con yeah yeah
their licensing application but once it
was pointed out they added it quickly
and said oh we always knew it was there
well if you always knew it was there
why'd you leave it
out um I think that it is concerning it
goes back to again it's not my area of
expertise but uh the manufacturing
process that I talked about that
typically the manufacturing process for
these things was on a very small batch
using a pretty time intensive process um
but when you roll rolled it out to
billions of doses uh you had to change
on the Fly and I'm not sure that they
had uh perfected their process and
especially in uh getting rid of
contaminants as a chemical engineer you
know you know it takes a long time to
perfect you yes I uh in the in the 990s
I worked with Dr sulk on a a analogy for
HIV using the polio approach that he
used and uh we we did cell culture batch
small cell cult culture batches to grow
HIV which we then inactivated and used
Freud's adant to as a vaccine as a
prototype that he attempted uh that was
unfortunately unsuccessful but had uh I
think it did a lot to further the
science and the understanding of what
HIV was doing in the population at that
time so it was it
was good mechanisms for science um I I
actually did have a a question um with
regard to to natural immunity and covid
what what have you seen uh so I I myself
I'll just share a brief personal
testimony is that I had covid uh my
oxygen levels went down um I had not
been vaccinated and I had to be
hospitalized I was in um ICU for nine
days and hospital for 14 days and and
um uh fortunately was not put on a
ventilator um and immediately uh after
that is someone was Physicians were
suggesting oh you should get vaccinated
and I said what happened to natural
immunity um and so I do you have some
comments on on that two two things
one yeah when when Physicians were
saying that and actually Thomas massie's
um phone calls with some of the FDA
people recently showed you they had no
evidence on actually getting the vaccine
after you had had co uh and in fact to
say that would be safe and effective is
completely Russian roulette meaning you
they had no data you were actually
excluded from The Trial if you had
previously had Co which I you know makes
sense if you're trying to do a trial um
but the
uh the
um the uh the interesting thing and this
is really more inside baseball just
talking to Dr Redfield the interest so
up
until up until really Omron I mean I had
a I had a patient base of about 7,000
antibodies I had I had the machine
basically that orthol clinical makes
that could tell me uh what your Sero
positivity in your serot titer was and
so I just ran I have my own Reference
Lab which again goes back to how
interesting I am um but
uh I maybe had one person that had out
of that 7,000 that had been
reinfected
um maybe two I mean it was counting them
on on you know fingers
okay which is one of the reasons that I
started to question the Orthodoxy even
more because that was not what was being
told you know people can get infected
their antibodies Wayne No One antibodies
Wan they doubled every three months um
so it was like completely it was like
they were just stating something that
was either they had never investigated
or they knew was
untrue um but then Omron came along and
Omron that's a whole different story on
probably how Omron anyway still don't
know totally about Omron it's this
totally different lineage it's nothing
to do with previous uh SARS Co 2
infections just appears out of nowhere
in November of 20 uh
22 um but it revealed not only kids got
infected but also everybody that had
gotten covid previously started getting
infected um with so natural immunity in
this it does matter that you've had Co
but one of the ways the spike protein
was manipulated and that could be
something that you could discuss but uh
was they tried to make the spike protein
in a way that it did not um alert or
activate your inate immune system okay
so your inate immune system is kind of
like your alarm system for the body and
again this comes from just kind of
knowing what they were trying to do in
the lab uh and so when you downregulate
that innate immune response uh you're
kind of your alarm is shut off and so
your alarm system doesn't work well and
so it makes it really hard for the
natural immune processes to actually
work your protective immune responses
which are a lot dependent on your innate
immune system so it's just unique and
again even how they glycosilated the
spike meaning like the sugars and it it
makes it very hard for the body to find
and get rid
of and Dr Redfield will tell you about
where the alanines are on each of the
that's not that's beyond my expertise
but it's interesting how they changed up
the domains that would have interacted
and actually um had an immune response
follow up yeah but uh
so I'm almost shocked because as science
you don't know what the outcome for that
will be you can't know what the outcome
for that would be so you're you're
putting something in that has
no evidence to
support a knowable long-term effect yeah
and we we still I mean again that study
didn't look at long-term effects I think
probably Aon Siri probably gave you all
a schooling on how long actually people
follow follow up after vaccines you know
it's it's uh it's not what we
think uh you mentioned the Omron which
is like was a different variant variant
of the SARS 2 um and that a lot of
people were Contracting that that it
already
had covid why what made that variant
different and um well when you think
about natural immunity and then how a
virus mutates over time you know the
more likely it is to the virus that you
had the more likely you probably have
immune you know activity that can a will
help you prevent from getting it um when
you have something that has a totally
different
lineage um all bets are off
so when you say totally different
lineage me had no it had it had nothing
to do with Alpha Delta
Luhan it appeared as you all remember it
supposedly appeared in South
Africa in November or October
um there's an interesting paper and
again I can I can give this to the
committee um that the closest thing that
that SARS Cove to uh in terms of they're
they're able to run genetics and look at
protein structure and how it interacts
with uh different mammals
and the most recent thing that it
appeared that it had interacted with was
mus muscularis which is a a lab Mouse um
and so like meaning everything about it
like that was the most recent species to
to interact with it if that makes sense
so again I'm not saying we know that for
sure but it was an interesting paper uh
representative
Belcher thank you madam chair and I I
caught a little something there I'd like
to drill down on just to to see if I'm
understanding correctly because it's
thought I've had
before obviously the weight of the
evidence would now suggest that covid-19
original strain was not a naturally
occurring virus but rather something
that very much appears again the weight
of the evidence to have been developed
at a uh Chinese military laboratory in
Wuhan with the input and perhaps funding
of the NIH through intermediary Eco
Health Alliance who has now been
sanctioned by the federal government um
for withholding
information uh are you suggesting now
based on some of this genetic analysis
that was
done that there was a strain that came
about sometime during the pandemic that
was
sufficiently genetically dissimilar to
anything else that was out there at the
time that it might suggest a secondary
laboratory release
so it is it's a possibility I mean the
other thing that they
stated around that time you'll remember
that they were say it's probably in some
HIV patient that never cleared the virus
and made mutations and I don't know if
y'all maybe you probably didn't read the
stuff that the literature that uh
meaning because everyone would they're
still dumb bounded on like why a virus
all of a sudden appears with no previous
history to a pre so I mean that is that
is one of the possibilities that there a
that something else was new I mean
because it is new when you look at you
know look at its relation to the
previous
virus follow up thank you madam chair
and just to dispel for anybody who's
watching that may sound like a crazy
question but given the modern technology
for things like Gene
editing is it really that crazy to
suggest that there could have been some
secondary playing around with this virus
at some point along the
way not at all I mean I
think the more we learn about what labs
are doing with gain of function the more
we need
to crack down on
it um in response to your patients that
maybe had the original covid and then
the Omicron did you notice a difference
in symptoms oh yeah yeah I mean the
Omicron was definitely much more um at
least at that time and still is less
thrombogenic less platelet activating
symptoms seem to stay mostly in the orox
so throat um and uh you know it did not
cause the crazy chest x-ray changes that
were associated with
Delta having had both um I noticed a
huge difference
between how my body was with one versus
the other um so
um that may explain I think uh why there
was such a huge difference um thank you
represent PO is
off thank you did you have any cases
when you had uh to send your patients
into for example hospital system and did
you have any input on followup
treatments and uh any you feedback and
so so yes so um when we talk about home
oxygen uh the European respiratory
Society at that time had had a uh
article that was talking about what we
call permissive
hypoxemia um which is a fancy term for
saying you know typically in medicine we
you know your SATs getting the 80s we
were were scared but interestingly
enough in Co it seems like these people
could hang out in the 60s and 70s and
again I'm not giving any medical advice
here I'm just kind of telling you and it
uh but they would be fine actually if as
long as they would sit there they were
you know what would happen though is
eventually if their lungs didn't recover
they would start to wear out so work of
breathing can be very tiring um and so
if the work of breathing tired out I did
have to admit them but we would admit
them to a place that could do eemo um
where cuz the last thing we want to do
is beat up their lungs cuz the lungs are
the problem um so ECMO uh you know was
the primary therapy now that wasn't it
was a salvage therapy in the hospital um
realm meaning after they'd beat the
lungs up on the ventilator for two weeks
they'd throw them on ECMO um but I've
seen a lot of patients that actually
that's why they survived was emmo the
other thing is interesting a number of
my patients that survived got apib and
they got put on uh a blood thinner um
you know so it was almost like thank God
you got apib while you're in the
hospital because you got the treatment
that you needed to get um which is again
these are just you know stories from the
people that I've taken care of but yeah
there was
two two people like that uh one passed
away um and then the other one
survived now one of the things that we
talked about and because you own a
practice um is health care worker
shortage um are you seeing that in your
practice Yeah I mean it's hard it's it's
hard to get good people at the time also
it's hard to keep good people because uh
some of the payment structures and most
of the hospital systems are currently
paying for that right now because they
were doing out of state nursing paying
three times the labor cost that they you
know and now they're all like we don't
have any money well you also stole all
the people that I uh because you could
pay them three times more because you
were getting so yes it is an issue um
but uh but what I it was interesting in
my cohort again I think this goes back
to why having a family company a small
practice is my uh my employees I kind of
look at as my second family and so you
know well my goal was to take care of
them throughout all this and that's what
we did and because I was willing to take
care of them I don't know because but I
think because I was willing to take care
of them they were willing to work and
and and stay and help so um what um in
speaking with different people and I
just spoke with someone on Tuesday who
was a first responder um in the in the
state and she was either told because
she wouldn't take the vaccine to either
mandatory retirement or they would uh
terminate her fire
her um and then also at our County
levels um if because of the Medicaid
Medicare
dollars um if you refused the vaccine
you were no longer employed yeah um and
do you think uh and so these people have
gone on to other things in their lives
and I don't think are coming back into
the healthcare system do you think that
created part of our issues it didn't
help
um a lot of it was interesting still
even if you look back at the the oan
mandate the medical provider mandate the
HHS mandate that all came out in
September
2021 um the only one that I think held
up which is crazy in the Supreme Court
was the healthcare worker
mandate which I thought was ironic
because wouldn't it be the healthcare
workers the doctors and other people
that might be able to make the best
decisions for themselves on whether they
need to be vaccinated or not again these
are people that defer to The Experts
right you know it was just that the OSHA
the OSHA part didn't hold up and then I
forgot what the other one was but uh
yeah I mean it's the med they they
attached it to your payment from
Medicare if you were in a hospital
system um I
think I don't know if that's still um
law I I don't I don't think it's it is
um at the moment I don't think it's um
one of the issues but I know even at the
county level uh contractors are
subcontractors couldn't go in unless
they were vaccinated so they're actually
having trouble getting work done um so
yeah um is there any advice that you
would impart to this committee as we
uh look at what we can do better in the
next pandemic we know that the next
pandemic will be different um the virus
or whatever it is is going to look
different in your professional
opinion what do you think should happen
at the state
levels um to
prevent um so that we can do better next
time to make sure all stakeholders are
at the table that all voices are being
heard that Biologicals are an option and
it's not a one-sized fits-all because
we're all
different yeah I think I think freeing
up Physicians to be able to do what they
think is right um and if they get any
push back making sure they are
represented correctly that they're doing
the right thing meaning if they get
fired by the hospital having you know
avenues for for that uh the other thing
is just I think the structure of most of
these Health authorities was never
evaluated because they never thought
that a health authority would become the
authoritarian uh monster that uh they
became and so there's a lot of states
that didn't even know that the person in
charge of whether you could open your
restaurant was something somebody you
couldn't fire and your legislators and
Governor couldn't do anything about
either and that is a recipe for disaster
so anybody with the authority to shut
down your freedoms has to be held
accountable in every way of structuring
it that way is just common
sense does anyone else have any
questions I'm sure we'll think of
Plenty um but Dr Von I can't tell you
how much uh I I think we all appreciate
you being here and the information that
you have given us
um wow um and some of the data uh I
think it's important for us to hear this
information and to get it out to our
citizens so that they can understand
that there are people that understand
and are out there that um know what's
going on uh especially in the terms of
uh long Co and vaccine injury um and
maybe we can get more people in this
state involved in that um to give these
people help um we've had parents in here
testifying and showing us pictures of
their children
um it's horrific yeah um it's it's it's
actually it's heartbreaking um so thank
you again so much for being here I
appreciate it and um I'd like to recess
us until uh 2 o' um is that too long I
think 2 o'clock will be good we'll
recess till 2 o'clock and come back and
uh maybe talk about the report a little
bit oh and another report that just came
out okay so uh we'll recess until 2:00
thank
you
e
e e
I am going to have to put us into recess
for another half hour until 2:30 uh as
other members have have been delayed so
we will recess until 2:30 thank
you
e
e e
good afternoon and welcome back to the
covid-19 investigative committee you're
probably surprised to see me in this
chair as I am um we're just opening up
while we wait for the rest of the
members for a few more minutes so if
you'll hang with us we will be back in
session to discuss a couple reports
thank
you
e
e e
so uh the doctor Dr uh V runs a large
Private Practice um overseas I believe
he said about 200 other Physicians uh
focusing largely on uh
Co acute long covid
and also vaccine injuries and effects
and he has an awful lot of um awful lot
of experience I believe I believe he
said that they've treated cumulatively
about 200,000 patients
um he's uh has a lot of experience
Beyond just I don't mean to say just
being a doctor but beyond being a
physician he's also has his a degree in
engineering um he is obviously a
businessman having running all that
um and he's also has experience he's
testified before Congress um
uh he's out of
Alabama yep yep down south um so it it
was very nice bit of testimony
um actually most of it was just question
and answer we we had an awful lot of
questions about a whole broad range of
of subjects
um and it it was very very interesting
um now whether there was a lot of brand
new
material I think a lot of it was sort of
stuff we've at least tangentially heard
from other people as well um but
nonetheless uh it was it was very
interesting very
informative
um yeah it was very
good
e
e e
[Laughter]
am thank you I don't know you have I
need to out of here that's fine um I
believe did represent Belia open the
meeting he did I okay thank you
uh well what are we discussing
that's up to the chair I just assumed
that uh you guys were discussing the
report and uh no no we were waiting for
you waiting for esteemed
chair
Shucks um well good afternoon representa
po
off uh thank you Madame
chair uh
so just to open the discussion so uh I
think our report should uh cover
different topics that we discussed
before as priorities uh for committee
like we were discussing effect on
education and
uh so and also if
possible um uh I think uh it would be
nice to document again who were people
testifying in front of our Comm Mee uh
and also I don't know if it's possible
but if possible to outline what uh
documents were submitted uh to for the
record of the committee so uh to have it
listed in our final
report um I think that's that's good um
some of the documents I mean I don't
think we can attach them um all of them
to the uh report because I think uh it
would be too many um represent pull off
yeah yeah yeah even not attaching but
just mentioning the nature of the
document or name of a document name of
an article or uh some uh executive order
or something else that was
submitted so did um I think you
mentioned to me that um the researcher
sort of gave you a format for the
outline for this sort of report uh yes
and I can forward that off to everyone
she gave me
uh like a memorandum and then an example
of a report and I can send that off to
the entire committee uh I'll do that
right as we before we leave tonight yeah
I mean usually they do exactly what you
said representative they say what our
mission was they say how many meetings
we had who the people were I mean we're
going to have our own website right so
we can link to the website for a lot of
the documentation and if there's
specific documentation you want to call
out we can we can mention that um I
think the challenge may be what you were
just just what categories we want to
talk about within the report because we
heard an awful lot of information and
some of it is within the purview of the
state and others of it isn't so I don't
know uh representative beler said he had
a couple of reports he wanted to discuss
that said represent thank you m
chair the ones I have seen so far
the part that we need to focus on is the
findings of the committee and then what
are the recommendations of the committee
um those should not be
really robust as per se they should be
more of a short narrative succinctly
said and then at that point in time you
can go into what it is that you want
like you said all the attachments and
documentation that we went through but I
think key to it is going to be what are
the what are the findings we have what
you going call them bullet points and
then at that point in time what are the
recommendations and I would like to have
the committee focus on what are the key
findings not every finding but the key
ones that we all can agree on and then
what are the recommendations that we
have based upon the
findings I I think one of the key
findings that we found was um in regards
to um
a lot of the information that was
filtered down to the state came from the
federal government um and as we
discussed um you
know the state could only act on what
they were being
fed
um the other thing is is and we
discussed that a lot of fear was
instilled into the populace and uh what
steps can the state take take in the
future to mitigate some of that
[Music]
um because you're being bombarded on a
day-to-day level and I think that that
plays a Hu played a huge factor into the
whole uh pandemic and turned families
against family members
and people against people and we have to
remember that we're all
we were all we were all in this together
um and even though we may have different
opinions doesn't mean one was right and
one was
wrong but and then you know when we
listened to the honorable Betty gay she
said you know you know she had some
different ideas but bringing different
uh ideas together to get to the so
everyone can understand everyone else's
Viewpoint and maybe one is better you
know one is making more sense and one's
not as rational but it to dismiss people
is not really um people need to feel
valued and heard I I concur I would say
that a couple of things I've taken away
and you hit upon one of those and that
is the fact there was the Federal
Government a lot of the information came
from the federal government as a state
we don't have the resources to reinvent
the wheel so we have to take on face
value what the federal government is
providing for information information
secondly I would say the issue comes
down to is how much State Control versus
local control and do we at this point in
time have a very very strong State
control or do we somehow again the state
becomes the vehicle to bring the
information from the federal level down
to the local level and that's the
tension between the state control versus
local control and then the other part I
would say is to you really hit upon the
nail it's the Fear Factor and what is up
happening is
and this is not the state when I say the
state it's us in this room right here we
had competing narratives we it became
politicized and it was like my narrative
is more correct than your narrative no
my narrative is more correct than your
narrative so we had competing narratives
that are out there which to your point
tore families apart to our friendships
apart because people didn't know which
narrative so if I was going to look at
it in hindsight we should have all got
together and had a narrative and not
have competing narratives so that's my
take on it and and thank you for saying
that and um but that's what this rep
this committee is here for right is to
see okay this this is what happened we
can do better next time and next time we
don't know what the pandemic's going to
be or how it's going to react it's going
to be completely different um so
uh but um I I think you know that's I
think we have to approach that and recog
at least we're we in this committee are
sitting down recognizing some of the
issues and we can sit here and talk
about them and I think that hopefully
the public can see that we can do that
um nicely and you
are doesn't mean one person's right and
one person's wrong and I I think that's
really important represent yeah I mean I
do too so I was just sort of thinking
about this because I've written a few of
these reports and I'm not volunteering
to write this um but the a lot of the
findings can be like some really basic
stuff like I I uh think uh Trisha Tilly
came in she had a timeline right I think
the timeline would be really helpful to
have included in the report um uh and
that way we our findings don't have to
be the list of events and then you know
maybe we can build to some extent about
that but you know one of our findings
can be um unfortunately through the
course of the pandemic the the um the
discourse became very uh polarized and
polarizing um and you know then a
recommendation can be you know I don't
know how you solve that but to really
work harder on messaging that is not
politicized and polarizing and more and
more unified I mean that's sort of how
you can break it up I I mean yeah I mean
it's easy for us to say this now because
we're sitting here playing the quarter
you know right but we can have but we
can have that as a finding and then we
can because I I mean if I'm remembering
I watched the live stream from uh Dr
Chan that was one of the things that he
pointed to so unfortunately we haven't
really had somebody here to present the
homeland security report but I'm sure
there are some things in there that just
when we're doing our report it's going
to sound familiar to us so um but
there's there must be other things that
we can say representative weary then
representative Merchant yeah just just a
comment I think um I think the point
about conflicting narratives is good but
I think that it goes uh further than
that and that we were getting
conflicting data and so I think you you
know we I think we're fairly rational
people here in New Hampshire and we tend
to form good rational decisions um but I
think when we were getting conflicting
data and not uh kind of testing that and
sourcing it out I think that let that's
what ultimately led to the the
conflicting narratives if I you know
that's my perception um you know I I I'm
a chemical engineer I've done a lot of
process investigations where there's
something messed up and you know what
what
what invariably happens is someone has
made an assumption about something and
they've marched off in that direction
because of that and until you you know
stop everybody slow them down and get
them say well how how did you know that
was accurate you what how are you
assured that that data is correct then
you you can't really do a proper
investigation you can't make proper
decisions following that so I I your
point is well taken but I I think it it
really goes deeper than that and I think
that's the challenge for New Hampshire
in the future is sorting out what is
accurate data and what is
not I totally agree with that I would
say
that we are trying to build a plane
while we're basically flying it
um and it's a challenge I look back in
the Spanish Flu back in 1916 17 18 the
same issues we have today they had as
well and it comes back to the Fear
Factor it was again competing thoughts
back to competing data what people
thought was right versus wrong some
cities did it one way one city did it
another way it wasn't until after the
dust settled we go back and look at the
data in hindsight you said okay that
prevailed and it made sense that didn't
but when you're going through the air
and you're trying to build a plane at
the same time it's hard to sort through
the data I don't disagree that there is
competing data and the question at that
point in time is how do we somehow I
think take the competing data and not
turn it into supporting our competing
narratives and that's where I think it
came down to is somehow as a state and I
don't know whether we can do this
because we also have the federal
government so the federal government we
don't live in an isolation
so you had the federal government
sometimes you could have competing
narratives between the federal
government and the state government and
within the
states so I what I'm trying to get to
is I think we did as best as we could
however could we have done better in
some ways yes but I think that's what we
talk about the recommendations and the
findings is we had all this competing
data competing information if you will
we had uh society and people out there
looking to say which one do I believe
and that's so
hard I agree and the other thing is is
well we just had testimony this morning
from Dr Devon and then uh representative
beler as we were discussing uh he
someone did a study and prior to the
pandemic there was a 70% confidence rate
in Physicians he then said it was down
to 40% but as we were speaking represent
Bel you got a report that said it's at
31.7% people trust their
doctors um and so we know that
the not only in the medical industry but
in government we've lost the trust of
the people um and we need to gain that
trust back because if there's another
pandemic we can't have it can't be
Helter Skelter we need to make sure the
people are going to trust what they're
hearing and M chairman chair lady sorry
I would say it's probably one of the
most important takeaways from this is
that how do we get the trust back of the
voters citizens and people in our state
because they look to us for guidance and
if they don't have that trust in us then
we don't have much to hang or hand
on I 100% agree with
you represent
beler thank you madam chair and uh on
precisely that topic um one as I as I
mentioned there was a couple reports I
wanted to discuss one of them came
across uh earlier and this was this was
just
released uh very recently this is a and
I sent it out via email as well this is
a a United States House House of
Representatives um report of findings
called we can do this an assessment of
the Department of Health and Human
Services covid-19 Public Health campaign
and this this is looking specifically at
a messaging campaign that uh was
undertaken at a cost of more than $20
million per month uh by The Firm fors
Marsh group um on behalf of the
Department of Health and Human Services
and there's quite a lot of findings it's
a I don't expect you'll probably want to
read the whole thing it's 113 or
something pages long um but there's
there's some very interesting findings
and I I'd be happy to discuss some of
them in in in detail but the thrust of
it is that this report lays at the foot
of this particular firm um a messaging
campaign to the public that was not
keeping up with what was known
scientifically at the time that the
messaging was being done and as a result
caused a collapse in public confidence
in uh in in the government's sort of
role in in this representative Bel was
that at the federal level or state level
yes that was the Federal level Federal
level thank
you I mean I think as part of our
findings we really have to say that the
pandemic caused panic and you know we
had agency person after agency person
come in and just say you know what a
difficult scenario it was for them and
they were really they were really
scrambling you know we were dealing with
remote situation when we I mean now we
take it for granted but it didn't really
exist at that time um and I mean I think
the agency people were really doing the
best that they could do um but I think
our findings have to reflect the
atmosphere that existed especially in
the in the beginning of the pandemic I
think that's really um important
but if I was going to have a
recommendation I would say that our
Public Health uh you know system we
really have to I mean I don't I think
there was probably some standard
operating procedures in place for a
pandemic something like this but I think
that our systems really need to be tuned
up and upgraded so that in a situation
like this if it comes up again we're not
scrambling like crazy I mean I assume
there are things in place but hopefully
they'll reanalyze their systems and and
we'll be better prepared the next
time I mean I agree but I mean I also
think that you know in light of the fact
um we need to recognize
that depending on what area of Public
Health they're in you may need to bring
in Engineers or industrial hygienist
it's not just you need to bring in other
areas because they're only looking at
one aspect of it and there's many many
aspects of dealing with the pandemic and
I think it's important um you know just
with uh Dr Chan being
here La last week and I asked him about
um you know one of the things that we
heard that could have helped mitigate
things like almost immediately and
schools and things was air filtration
and ventilation well yeah we didn't have
the money for that well what is that but
it still would be to me that would be
under public health because you're
looking at mitigating a virus um but his
Department didn't really focus on that
um according to what he his testimony
was and correct me if I'm wrong um you
know
so sometimes we need to bring in others
so that they can look at the different
areas I mean I think that's great that's
one recommend ation that we say that the
response to that I mean and this may
even be in the homeland security report
that unfortunately our agencies have
worked in a sort of they they worked in
a sort of a siloed fashion and over time
they may have come together but any
response to a pandemic really has to be
an integrated one that brings in stuff
like what you were just saying and and
um I I mean I think there was an attempt
to to do that but they should like have
systems in place to make sure they do it
in the future but funding of course is
always
really difficult well well of course
funding is always difficult and and the
thing is is you
know no
one in this state should take lightly
what everybody in the departments were
going through at the time of the
pandemic that they were working hard and
had the best interests
of the state in mind I mean we have to
be thankful for that um so we all have
to
recognize that important and and and I
did I I wrote something up pretty
quickly um I was just going through some
things and one of the things I said is
is the decision could not have been made
lightly but as most of us have lived
through this in the state we will
remember that the fear was instituted in
the population we must remember
um that what we heard much testimony and
do a look back at what happened we
realized that it was a difficult
decision that the decision makers had to
make I mean we have that is important I
think it's really important as a Top
Line message this this would be in the
introduction they they were working
really hard and doing the best they
could do uh exactly I I actually
forwarded this to uh representative
beler and asked him you know I said that
I think that this here um talking about
how we shut down and unknown and how we
have to be thankful and I even even
closed with
um you know that we must look at you
know thank our our people that were
involved in this um I think it's really
important to thank
everybody I I totally I totally concur I
say that it's not just as a legislative
body there's the trust with the
populace is also trust with the state
agencies and I think what you're hitting
upon is the trust with the state
agencies that we recognize the
challenges they faced and the challenges
that probably going to come next time so
it's I commend you for wording at that
way because I think we need to be sure
that they know we
have their our support we appreciate
what they' done I agree with
you I mean we to leave something like
that out would be fool hard
in my
opinion and I just go back to what I
mentioned before I don't if you had a
chance to read through it and it goes
with a pandemic and that's the Fear
Factor it's it's when you have such
unknown and you're living in a vacuum
you're trying to figure out what's right
or wrong and there competing data
whatever is going on out there it's
extremely difficult to deal with people
when they become emotional and IR
rational I agree with you well we're
sick I mean you know
dying right so um but yeah so does
anyone else have anything represent po
off uh today uh during the morning we we
discussed uh um briefly
compensations uh to certain injured
individuals but uh we we even earlier we
discussed like New Hampshire like as you
know like
previously uh returned some fines to
businesses issued uh during uh lockdowns
uh and uh I I mean uh currently some
states uh take measures on people who
were probably needlessly fired to for
refusal of covid vaccine mandated in
their business and those people receive
compensations but for example
for um uh even though most people who
received vaccine they seem fine we we
obviously have people who had uh severe
vaccine reactions to the point of um
being uh handicaped or otherwise s
injured and uh existing
uh existing um mechanism of comp
compensation are often honorous and not
working and overwhelmed with number of
people uh who want
compensation uh uh so maybe it would be
prudent to include some recommendation
into
report uh as as government is reacting
to pandemic uh that there needs to be
some safety mechanisms uh better safety
mechanisms for people who are
inadvertedly
injured uh by by government actions
um act uh thank you represent po off uh
so um from Dr vau this morning um he has
just I believe received a grant in his
State uh to do research on long long
covid um which I think will benefit
everybody um and the effects and uh he's
documenting uh he's
I guess it's just he's just work getting
the grant uh going so um knowing that
that's going to be out there I think
will be extremely important to people
not only in New Hampshire but throughout
the country uh to understand what his
findings are going to be and looking at
that um but as far as compensation
represent P up I've seen some of the uh
reports coming through and they're in
different states for um people who have
um were fired or let go of you know a
Blue Cross worker who was forced uh to
leave his position uh because he refused
the vaccine um and then there was
another one working for Bart um that is
being
compensated um but I don't think I th
those are individual cases that are
being brought
before I don't know if that would happen
in New Hampshire
um only because we are in at will state
um and I can just tell you that on
Tuesday and I'm just going to say this
for the committee so that everyone hears
this I met with a woman about a
different topic had no idea you know for
some reason I said oh I have a committee
meeting on Friday and told her what our
committee was she goes oh I was one of
them and I'm like what do you mean she
goes I was a first responder in the
state I was the top first responder
uh in my area they actually put radios
in my personal vehicles I was the first
one they would call and because I
refused the vaccine they said you either
do a mandatory retirement or we will
fire
you and she had to find another source
of income um but those are some of the
stories that you're talking about but we
are in at will state just so you
recognize that represent
beler thank you madam chair um yeah when
it comes to the the the vaccine issue I
do think obviously so much of it was
Federal and because it was I mean it was
an item that was recommended by the
state I think there's a necessity to
bring in what we know which one of the
most important things I think we've
discovered at this point is that when it
came to making recommendations for the
vaccines it they our state really first
of all didn't seem from what we know
didn't seem to have access to any sort
of detailed Federal data um that we may
have heard about and they were for the
most part just taking Federal and
professional
association um evaluations and
recommendations and guidance at face
value which is seems to be what they
did President belter I hear what you're
saying the challenge I think as a
clinician when you're in the midst of an
epidemic is what data is is out there
that's going to support any
recommendation um a lot of it comes from
your colleagues a lot of it comes from
things you've heard worked in some other
capacity and it's very very difficult I
mean that's why we do double bind
studies we we do a lot of studies out
there we go through it and we rely upon
the data that comes through those
studies to show us what works and what
doesn't work the challenge I think I
would face is that if you don't have
those studies and you're collecting the
data going through the study it's hard
to differentiate and make that clinical
judgment so I hear what you're saying
and not disagreeing with you but just
trying to explain that when you're in
the midst of it all it's very difficult
to say what's the real data that I can
hang my hat
on and I you take the recommendations
because that's all you have until you
come through Beyond it that's all yes
thank you I I think that's basically the
point I was trying to make is that we
were taking the federal government's
guidance that we they were providing to
us and we
were that's just what it was we didn't
develop our
own recommendations based on our own
studies or anything like that we we took
the professional data that was available
and we and we went with that I I I want
to be sure I'm agreeing with you but I
want to be sure why I'm agreeing with
you at the same time I think we actually
on the same page on that one um so I
want to say thank
you there is Common Ground out there
here there's always Common
Ground sometimes we we we have the same
goal we just have different ways of
getting there I've used that many times
myself when I was on the Board of
Pharmacy with a colleague of mine and we
would
have very robust discussions we agreed
upon the end result we totally disagreed
upon the path to get
there well I'm just trying to sorry I'm
sorry didn't me jump in um so I'm just
trying to think about this in terms of
like findings and then recommendations
so I don't know quite how you break it
up but a recommendation could be that
the our Public Health folks continue to
try to figure out a way in their systems
for response to pandemics uh to try to
find some space to
to to analyze the data more
independently if it's impossible before
I mean unless it's impossible before
issuing guidance I mean that's I mean
that that's the kind of stuff that we
can say that I think we can all agree
on right I mean so at you know we all
know what we've heard in this committee
I mean the testimony is the
testimony
um and we've listened we've as had
chance to ask
questions uh and discern you know and
then if we didn't think something
something was right we can ask it again
to you know to get to the bottom of it
and um so we have findings through that
we also in listening to that have been
able to discern really some of the
points that
were you know the trust the fear the not
coming together those have been loud and
clear those findings we can't
dispute um and so we can approach this
from
findings but we all again we have to
look at what we did positive so we we we
have to emphasize the
positive and realize that our findings
are after the fact that we weren't this
is now not living through the
pandemic um so that that that's and
that's why in in the beginning we have
to recognize that um
and so by way no no means should this be
people feel like this is a criticism but
this is going to be a tool going
forward um and be and that's what I'm
hoping that it will be a tool and then
as we have data we can give data of
things that we've received even if it
was from the federal government or
federal guidance and say look at this is
what we found out from F that was at the
federal level this is what the state was
privy to because
unfortunately it all went hand inand and
as uh representative groer last week was
talking about you know we have a
healthcare worker shortage
well and I agree but also at the same
time we lost like this first responder
and a lot of healthcare workers because
of the mandates and not only because of
the mandates that's and some of them
were imposed because if you wanted to
receive payment like at the county
nursing homes you wouldn't receive
payments if you didn't impose those
mandates and that was Federal
guidance and not state so we have to
distinguish between the two even though
it affected us at the state level we
need to point out that why did it affect
us at the state level it wasn't through
any fault at of the state it was through
the federal government and then the
question becomes what can we do as a
state to try and mitigate that in the
future or ask our
Congressional do you understand where
I'm going right I I totally concur with
I understand where you're going I'll go
back to the comment you talked about
before being an
any um what do you call it any will as
far as an employment is concerned at
will thank
you and that's a tough one because you
know we really in this state take
Independence pretty seriously so we
don't want to infringe upon the
independence of the business
community so that's a struggle too is
recognizing that there is going to be
that issue between the state
philosophy of Independence and what that
means to the worker not saying we're
going to solve it but it's recognizing
that that is in fact an issue that
that's out there so if you had the
federal government coming back and
saying this is what you have to do it
almost puts the employer at risk because
they can't get the reimbursement they
have no choice so you're raising a
really good
point earlier Barbara and that actually
is is why our committee came together
because there continues to be a lot of
um how should I say disagreement on the
way the the the various agencies played
out and the systems played out and that
I
mean that's why we're here right right
right because and and it's it's that
disagreement and then in the in the
testimony that we had I mean you guys uh
brought in a lot of folks that you know
they really had issues the way it played
out and that was part of what the you
know so we can talk about that um anyway
that's why we're we're here so anyways I
just wanted to reiterate that that I
really agreed with you and that's the
point and I would say when we first
started I'll be when we first started
this committee we were probably like you
know it's going to be really hard to
come to an agreement but it's because as
you said there's a lot of disagreement
out there that's really unfortunate and
one of the things we're working toward
is to try to sort of bring consensus on
a on a few issues that I think we all
can agree on so yeah you
know out well on the other end here and
to follow on that President able is the
fact that this committee worked through
a lot of challenges yeah but at the end
we have come together that in itself is
quite an
accomplishment so I think we need to be
sure we don't l side of that within the
report to commend the people in this
committee that yes we heard we listened
but we actually pulled something
together that I think we all can come to
an agreement on yeah and I mean I think
if we can agree that we're not going to
throw a whole bunch of people under the
bus I mean I don't I I don't want to
crush them under the wheels I think
everybody did the best they can they can
do um but that doesn't mean like okay
DHHS you really need to keep your eye on
the situation with long covid or you
really need to keep your eye on the
situation on vaccines as they play out
over the years you know I mean all that
that sort of thing so where are we with
that kind of a recommendation I'm
concerned about long Co and people do we
need resources Financial Resources to
help those people get through it do we
need to find out how to um ensure that
they get the care they need that they
don't get hit financially because if
they are falling outside of the
constraints of their insurance policy
whatever it's going to be I think that's
one of the things we could look at and
saying how do we ensure that the people
that have long Co have been impacted by
the epidemic or pandemic that they have
the resources they need to get the care
they need I'll let representative Bela
speak to all of
that thank you well first I just I
wanted to quickly agree with what was
said before that I think in in the
report where there is area for criticism
and I'm sure there will be some area for
criticism it's I think it would be best
be levied at the level of the agency and
and and Branch not at individuals the
point isn't going to be we're not
looking to indict or impeach people
through a report it's it's a matter of
what could have been done better and how
did we do better in the future and
that's I think that's the way to look at
the the bus
yeah um unfortunately I'm going to have
to leave now because I was going to try
to get at 4:00 because my computer died
um it's on the o table I'm going to try
to rescue it and see if it needs a
transmission we'll see what's going to
go on so uh wish me well um well thank
you so just really quickly before you
leave I mean I'm jumping ahead so the
idea is somebody's going to be
generating or because are do we have to
get this in by November 1st I I don't
know um I like we kind of do that's what
it says but it doesn't say that in our
Charter
yeah I just kind of told this oh speaker
that that was kind of like the due date
but um also I just want to let
representative Bela speak to long covid
because he can actually answer that
question really quick for thank you I'm
sorry can you just re repeat the
question I I I need to refresher as to
what it was the question I have is that
it's now become evident that there are
patients that came down with covid have
what they call long covid and they're
suffering the long-term effects of it
what I want to ensure that somehow in
the insurance policies of the insurance
department whatever it's going to be two
things one is that they can have access
to their insurance and not have it
carved out and all a sudden it's no
longer covered and then number two that
the state needs to either was Medicaid
whatever it's going to be representative
belard that there's Financial Resources
to be sure that we can get those
patients the care they need because I
think it's no fault to them they came
down with Co regardless of the reason
for it being but we need to be stewards
of their
care yes thank you I I would I would
tend to agree I think there's certainly
room to look at What mechanisms are in
place to well first of all I think for
the most part under current law there
shouldn't be anyone to cut them off from
insurance um I think it's important to
look at making sure that continues
and um I
think there's
some going to be some issues as to
whether what degree certain things are
state level versus Federal level but
that could even involve potentially
making a recommendation for a resolution
to our federal delegation or something
of that nature so yes thank you I mean
it we can also in our recommendations we
can also say something like that needs
more study and we weren't able to
complete you know because I've done that
before like one of the recommendations
is we should look at this some more they
should look at that it's not something
we would do but somebody else could do
right and just having Dr Devon here
talking about how he just got money from
his uh Grant from the uh uh state of
Alabama uh to start looking into this
because it is a real issue um and the
other thing is is to make sure that
doctors themselves are recognizing that
there is long covid and that they really
need to start documenting that and
looking at it and I think that's a real
concern car I want want to say thank you
luck to the good luck to the o thank you
are we going to try to meet once more
November 1st November 1st okay so will
you be able to come you okay all right
go ahead I'll be thinking of you though
thank you have a great
weekend uh uh what I would like to do is
um try and circulate the report
represent
beler uh before next Friday
if that's if that's doable I'd like to
look at it and just uh peruse it and
before you send it out to the entire
committee um if you don't mind um I do
want to send out the um the sample that
Kristen uh just sent to me yesterday I
just got that yesterday um and have her
her you know so that everyone can
understand what what a committee report
looks like and what my is involved in
that so I want to send that out to the
entire committee
um and uh we'll meet next I have next
Friday's meeting is scheduled at 10:
a.m. um and
uh I don't know about anyone else but
this has been a true learning experience
for me as
uh yeah I mean I can't say that I came
to it with
enthusiasm but it's been a you know and
I've appreciated working uh with you
guys I don't think otherwise we would
have been all working together and um
it's been a real Voyage of of Discovery
so I guess the only thing I I hope we
can get the
report s in advance because it's going
to be re I mean I would be uncomfortable
voting on a report if I just have it
that morning and unfortunately after
November 5th we're like I mean who knows
where the elections will go maybe we'll
all be sitting here and maybe we won't
well we're all in office until what
December 3rd yeah I guess that's right
um but I do think we should try to wrap
it up um as soon as we can and
um I I just I just want to say you know
we'll see where the report works out and
if there are things we can't agree on
then there's some things we can't agree
on and I don't want to walk away from
the experience with ill will if we just
can't come to you know with there may be
recommendations we agree with and and
recommendations we don't and I think
we'll do our best to all come together
and we'll just I mean I haven't seen the
draft report but I guess I mean that
from the heart I don't want that to sort
of disrupt our otherwise good working
relationship it's okay to agree to
disagree and I don't think uh that
anyone on this committee should have ill
will towards anyone else um I
think uh that everyone's been respectful
to each each other um and hoping that
the that we all conducted ourselves in a
manner becoming of Representatives for
the citizens of New Hampshire um and I
think that is really what is important
and uh you know getting to know each
other a little bit better as as people
um is important um at the end of the day
we're all here to do what's best for the
New Hampshire citizens we may agree on
some things and we may disagree on some
things but it's okay
yeah so we'll
see try to wrap it up then for November
1 and
then yes I mean honestly got this is an
enormous subject and I think we can only
do the best we can do
right and I think our recommendations if
a lot of them are just you know we got
to look at this be more we really have
to be conscious of this we have to be
conscious of that blah blah blah I mean
there's there's nothing wrong with that
considering the breath of the
topic correct and we all have to realize
that you
know this is something that we haven't
seen in over a hundred years um not s
none of us are scientists sitting on
this on on this committee um certainly
not my area of expertise although I have
learned a lot um and I think we've had
some good quality people in here
testifying all the Departments have been
uh very forthright and coming and
talking with us and uh I think that was
a good thing uh so so I just honestly
don't know if about time but I think we
should at least try to look a little bit
at the homeland security report if if we
can I don't know representative beler if
you have time but it' be be interesting
to just at least look at their executive
summary and see where they came down on
some of these issues I wouldn't be
surprised if there's some consensus with
them on some of the things that we're
saying I mean especially maybe messaging
I mean maybe you guys looked at it I
don't know I perused it a little bit
I'll probably do a little bit more over
the weekend um I have some time this
weekend so um but yeah yeah I mean that
could also give us some ideas
yeah representative beler I was just
going to say I haven't done a deep dive
I have looked it over at some degree I
think the the biggest utility of that
report is going to be when it comes to
looking at a section of a report talking
about stuff like integration of
different levels of government and um
Communications and stuff like that um I
think think that's where the most
utility for that report's going to come
well and then you know if if that I mean
that's we've talked a little bit is that
being part of our findings or
recommendation and then that would be a
good corroboration for what we've agreed
to or what what we think it's always
good to have
reinforcement uh anyone
else no thank you for being here this
afternoon I appreciate of course I think
we're all just like juggling an awful
lot of stuff and we did the best we can
here
so yeah we did it was it was big it was
big so we'll see where the report comes
out I mean honestly I just think we all
got to do the best we can do and
recognize
that that's what it is okay hope we
don't have to do have another pandemic
in the next couple of years that would
be terrible but anyways I would like to
thank everyone have a great weekend um
it looks like it's going to be pretty
nice little cool at night but I think uh
a nice weekend overall so uh November
1st at 10:00 a.m. and we will be
adjourned at 3:31 thank you